hey everyone this is shruti from simply
learn welcome to this web analytics full
course where we will learn how to
identify and fix issues of web pages
we'll begin the session by first
understanding what google analytics is
then we will understand different
concepts like how google analytics works
how to set up google analytics and get
insights of our web pages
after that we will look into event
tracking in google analytics and basics
of google data studio along with the
fundamentals and kpi of digital
analytics
we will then conclude this video by
discussing the opportunity options and
benefits of web analytics by the end of
this video i can assure you that all
your web analytics related queries would
have been answered for this training
with me i have our experienced web
analyst specialist rob stefan and
avinash
together we will take you through the
various topics of web analytics
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
without any further ado let's get
started welcome everyone this is rob
sanders with simply learn and today
we're going to talk about google
analytics i'm very excited to be with
you today because google analytics is
one of my favorite google platforms and
my favorite topics so let's talk about
what we're going to cover today and
we're going to start out with how to set
up a google analytics account and so
we're going to talk about everything
that entails including creating your
google analytics account we're going to
talk about setting up a property in your
account and what a property is we're
going to talk about setting up a
reporting view in your property and
we're going to talk about installing the
tracking code so those are the series of
steps we're going to go through today in
terms of setting up a google analytics
account so let's get right to it and so
really the prerequisite here when it
comes to setting up a google analytics
account is to have a google login and id
so when you actually go to google
analytics you need to be able to sign up
or sign in and so once you actually sign
in then you're gonna go walk through a
series of steps but really that's really
all you need to get the account going is
a google id and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new google analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here i'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the url for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
and analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the
most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and i'm gonna talk about why that's
important here in a minute and then
you're gonna choose your time zone and
the time zone is also important because
that's when the day starts and analytics
then the day ends based on that time
zone so the data that google analytics
collects starts and ends with that time
zone so very important to choose the
time zone your business is located in
okay and then you have some additional
options here okay so you have some
settings and so the first setting is to
allow google products and services so if
you opt into this then basically what
google is going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
i would go ahead and opt into that
that's of course recommended by google
it doesn't hurt to hear from google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business the second is
benchmarking so benchmarking to me is
something you should opt into so going
back to that industry and category we
chose jobs in education so by opting
into benchmarking basically what google
is going to do is share your data that
it collects on your website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com
it's going to share that data
anonymously
with others in the industry in this case
jobs in education and because you've
opted in it's going to do the same exact
thing for you it's going to share
anonymous data on other websites in the
same industry and the benefit of that is
we get to see
what other websites or how other
websites are performing compared to ours
what's the benchmark in our industry and
so the benchmarking to me is important
and i'm gonna go over that in a few
minutes when we go over the different
reports but to me i would always opt
into benchmarking because this is the
only report google provides in analytics
about how others in your industry is
performing versus your website okay so
it's a way to compare your website
performance against others in the same
industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
i would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically google allow google access to
your account and they'll be able to help
you if you occur or run into any issues
so these are the options in setting up a
google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few fields note that we
talking about a website right now so i'm
talking about demo.simplylearn.com
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
id now i'm going to accept the terms of
service i'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection i'm going to click accept
once i accept i'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking id
is the id associated with your account
and so
this number is going to be associated
with your account so your account id
starts with ua and it's gonna be this
number here now the dash one is the
property you set up so in this case i
set up
demo.simplylearn.com if i wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then i can certainly set up
multiple properties just know that every
property i set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
etc depending on how many properties i
set up so by default i set up one
property so my first property id is dash
one if i set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that id that account and property id is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking id up here
notice the tracking id and the snippet
of code now this snippet of code needs
to go on every page of your website that
you want to track and you don't have to
put it on every page but if you want to
track website behavior on every page
your website then it needs to go on
every page of your website so if you're
using a you know platform like drupal or
joomla or even more popular platform
like wordpress adding the tracking code
site wide is as easy as maybe adding a
google analytics plug-in to wordpress
for example and then just simply
plugging in the id now there's an
alternative to adding the google
analytics tracking code to your site and
that's google tag manager so google tag
manager is the way i would recommend
going so if you're not familiar with
google tag manager i would recommend
watching the
youtube video we have on google tag
manager you can just go to youtube type
in simply learn google tag manager and
this will give you a nice overview of
you know what google tag manager is and
how it works but basically this is the
way i would go and i would recommend
that in addition having google analytics
you set up a google tag manager account
and then that way you can put the
tracking code in google tag manager so
if i go to google tag manager and i just
go into an account on tag manager i can
just simply put in the google analytics
id right into tag manager and so if i
have it in tag manager then tag manager
is going to be the place that holds the
code and fires page view when somebody
comes to my website so that way i don't
have to add the tracking code to my
website if i do it in tag manager so
that's the recommended method for me is
to add the google analytics id
associated with tag manager if you can
associate it with tag manager then
that's the easier route to go versus
putting code on your website okay so
again take a look at the video we have
on youtube for google tag manager that's
the route i would go now once you do get
the tracking code on your website
whether that be through google tag
manager or through a plug-in or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
gonna happen is you're gonna start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
to your website now if you're not ready
to do that and you simply want to
basically understand how google
analytics works then i would recommend
getting access to google analytics demo
account and so if you just type in and
search google analytics demo account
basically what you're going to do you're
going to choose the first listing there
and you're going to go to demo account
so if you have a google analytics or
google login then all you need to do is
click on access demo account and so what
google's going to do is put this demo
account into your account and so it's
going to look something like this so if
i click on demo account here it's going
to add to my google analytics account so
i'm gonna have then access to the demo
account from google and google analytics
so i would recommend going this route
here if you're not familiar you're not
sure what you're getting yourself into
so think of the demo account as kind of
a test drive you're test driving google
analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a google account and if you have a
google account and you add the demo
account to your google analytics account
you're going to be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
i would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do
is just simply add the demo account and
then once you add the demo account
you're free to peruse around google
analytics to see the different types of
reports it has to offer now when you do
actually set up a google analytics
account you're going to have some
settings that you're going to want to
pay attention to so when you set up the
account you have the account name and
then you have a property so under each
property you have by default you're
going to have one view and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to google analytics anything
from adding users to your google
analytics account your google analytics
property review you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up google ads
you can
you know set up remarketing lists
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you can
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in google
analytics so if i'm an admin and i'm
looking at the google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
i click on the real time report and i
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users i actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here i can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent coming from
tablet here i can see how they actually
came to the website so this is the
referring source if they came from
say search or social i can see the
source there and i can see what pages
they're active on and then here i can
see what locations where they're located
and so if i want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview i can
certainly do that if i go to locations
under real time i could see a majority
of my users are coming from the united
states okay where are they coming from
i'll just click on traffic sources and
here i could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's google
it's either paid search or organic
search so i can see here it's organic
then i can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so i
could see currently have three active
users on the home page two active users
on the google's women's white tee page
so forth and so on now most importantly
if you have event tracking set up so if
you taking a look at our google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if i click on
events i'll be able to see what events
are firing so here i can see we have
event tracking set up and i can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here i can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and i could see
that these are the current events that i
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if i
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes i can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now i can see
i had one active user who entered the
checkout so that's goal number four so
in analytics you can have up to 20 goals
and so here i can see we have goal
number four has already had one active
user and so if i look at the last 30
minutes i can see i still have only one
goal over the last 30 minutes and that
was somebody who entered the checkout so
that's real-time reporting in summary it
just gives you an idea of what's
currently happening on your website and
so for me ideally if i'm launching a
campaign or let's just say you do a new
website redesign and you want to see how
users performing and behaving then real
time is a good option for you so you can
see how things are happening in real
time now let's jump down to audience
reporting so if i click on audiences
it's just right underneath real time i'm
going to see a number of different
reports available to me under audience
and so let's click on the audience
overview report so
audience reporting basically allows us
to get a sense of who is coming to our
website when i say who is coming to our
website it doesn't necessarily have to
be a specific person in fact google
doesn't allow personally identifiable
information in google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name a social security number
credit card information etc however we
can still paint a nice picture on who is
coming to our website meaning what
country
city or state did they come from what
language what device did they get to our
website from how old were they okay were
they male or female or other what
interest did they have what browser did
they use so we can paint a nice picture
based on all this information that
google analytics is providing us under
audience so if i go to audience overview
here i can see i have all these
different options available to me to get
a basic understanding of who is coming
to our website so for example i could
see a majority of the people coming to
our website
speak english and are from the united
states okay in fact that represents 61
of the users and so google analytics
does a great job of giving me an overall
percentage so if i have a 100 percent of
the users i could see 61 percent of
those users represented english speaking
users from the united states seven
percent represented english speaking
users from great britain and so when it
comes to analytics we have users and
users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's gonna happen is if a user
or when a user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied if it's the
first time they've been to your website
what google analytics is going to do is
store a cookie in the browser so when
that same user comes back another day in
the same browser analytics is going to
recognize that that cookie is in the
browser and so then analytics is going
to categorize that user as a returning
user okay so that's how analytics is
able to differentiate new versus
returning so if that user doesn't have a
cookie in the browser then analytics is
going to recognize that store the cookie
and then count that user as a new user
and so when you're looking in analytics
you're going to be able to see a
breakdown of new versus returning so
here i can see over three quarters of my
traffic over the past week here i can
see april 6 through april 12th three
over three quarters are new users to the
website here i could see about 23 24
are returning users okay so i can get a
good breakdown of what type of users are
coming am i driving new traffic am i
driving traffic that's been to my
website before what language are they
speaking okay i can also paint a bigger
picture how old are they are they what
gender are they do they come from mobile
so let's take a look at some of these
different reports under audience and so
if i skip down now to demographics i can
click on overview and when that report
loads i can see now under demographics
overview i can see the breakout of age
ranges and so here i can see the
majority of the traffic coming to my
site again over the past week now if i
want to change this date range i could
simply do that i can change the date
range just by clicking on the date range
and then maybe going say the last 30
days and i can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year i'm
going to choose the last 30 days i'm
going to click apply now i'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here i'm looking at the last 30
days and i can see almost 47 percent of
my users were in their age range of 25
to 34. now when it comes to gender i can
see
66
represent males so i can get a breakout
of gender and age as well as interest
and click on interest and look at the
overview there and see what the interest
is of the users who are coming to my
site based on in-market segments or
affinity i can also choose language and
location so if i want to know exactly
where my users are located when they're
coming to my website i can click on
location and here i can get a breakout
43
of the users of the last 30 days were
from the united states more importantly
i can align my audience with goals and
we'll talk about goals here in a minute
but here i can see if i have an
e-commerce website i can see of those 43
percent 0.29 of those converted or
purchased something and that equates to
94 transactions so i can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if i click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports i tend to spend a bit of time on
because i want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
google demo website i can see mobile
represents approximately 27
of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact via mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so google
analytics is telling me that yes i have
approximately 27 of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if i
look across this report i'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if i'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile i can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48
percent and bounce rate means that if a
user in this case from mobile landed on
a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an ecommerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48
percent mobile in desktop it's a little
bit lower at 41
now if i look a little bit further at
engagement i can see how many pages on
average do mobile users look at so
versus desktop it's a little bit lower
you can see 3.86
on desktop it's 4.5 now if i look a
little bit further in engagement i want
to be able to measure how long somebody
from mobile stays on the website if
they're bouncing at 48
but they're also looking at 3.8 pages
3.9 almost four pages per session then
that means in this report analytics is
telling me they're spending about two
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough i can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at point two
nine percent that's higher than desktop
at 0.07 it's lower than tablet but it's
higher than desktop and mobile has the
most transactions and since they have
the most transactions they have the most
revenue at 2 380 so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something i definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if i click save
i'm going to enter a name for this
report i'm just going to call it mobile
report and click ok and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if i close that up you can see
audience real time customization if i
click on customization if i click on
save reports i should be able to see my
save report here and i do so here i can
see mobile report if i click on it i can
simply go to the report i was looking at
before i saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature in analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so let's
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's go to benchmarking so
remember when we're setting up our
analytics account we had the option to
opt into benchmarking and i recommended
you do so and so if you did actually opt
into benchmarking then you're going to
be able to see
how your site compares to others in the
same industry so if i click on
benchmarking and then click on channels
what i'm actually able to do now is
compare my website with others in the
same industry so if i go back to say
jobs and education and i choose
education all education as my industry
vertical i should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how i compare with those
websites so i'm choosing all countries i
can narrow that down if i wanted to i
can just search for the united states i
can choose a specific state and then i
can choose a particular site size so
here i'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5 000 to almost 10 000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
united states sites that have 5 000 to
99999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria i chose now
if my site is similar meaning if i'm in
the united states if i'm in education
and i'm receiving 5 000 to
9999 sessions per day then i'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's shared
data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now i'm
looking at a channel report so if i want
to see how i compare to others in my
industry then i can go ahead and see by
channel for example am i driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
can see i'm not in fact i'm 76 77
percent worse in terms of the amount of
traffic being driven from organic search
so anything in red is going to show as a
negative result a negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if i look at engagement i
can see that i might not be driving as
much traffic but i can see that the
pages per session are better than the
site average or the industry average i
can see if i go over again looking just
at organic search i can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you to measure how you compare to
others in your industry and you could do
so by looking at location and devices so
if you opted into benchmarking when you
set up your account then you'll be able
to compare your website against others
in your industry in your country region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning or new came to our website and
so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how users got to your website
meaning how did users get to our website
did they come via organic search meaning
did they type something into google and
find you in the organic listing
analytics also groups users based on
whether they came to your site directly
meaning did they type in the url
directly into the browser or did they
bookmark your website and come back via
the bookmark so they're grouping users
under direct they also group users under
referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like twitter or facebook if
you're running paid search
meaning if you're running paid search on
say google then do they come from paid
search ads now if you're running display
ads on say google's network google's
display network that's a default channel
so analytics will group users there so
if they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so i can see
how many users came to the site from
each channel now if i want to drill down
on this report i can click on all
traffic and then if i click on all
traffic i can go to channels i can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now i can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users i can see
that number is about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so
just like we looked at with the
audience reports when it came to mobile
we can also look at engagement by
channel so just like mobile we looked at
bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is 0.17
okay so how google determines the
conversion rate they basically take
the number of transactions and divide
that by sessions so that means that over
the last 30 days organic search drove 38
123 sessions and of those 38 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in revenue so i'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
i can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by channel you'll
also get a summary so here i can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so i could see over the last 30
days i've had 54 000 users 49 000 of
them were new okay that meant that at
those 4 54 000 users i had 70 000
sessions i could see my average bounce
rate was 43 percent the pages per
session we're just over four and the
average session duration how long did
somebody stay on my website on average
about two minutes and 55 seconds the
average conversion rate was 0.14 and i
had a total of
transactions totaling 5500
okay and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is gonna have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
pdf if i click on pdf it's going to
allow me to export that as a pdf now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a google sheet you can
export it as an excel or you can export
it as a comma delimited file so here you
can see i can save it as a pdf if i want
to and if i click ok it's going to save
to my desktop or location of my choosing
and then i can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you in
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running google ads note that you
can connect google ads to analytics and
this is key because now i can see
how many people are coming from google
ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with google ads i'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here i'm
running a report based on campaign data
so i could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much i'm paying per
click and you can see on average i'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly i want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see i've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received
858 in revenue so you want to make sure
that you link up your google ads account
to your google analytics account for
this very reason you want to be able to
see how your google ads campaigns
perform once the users get to your
website and so i want to see if they're
engaging and i want to see if they're
converting so there are all sorts of
reports under google ads so you can look
at it by keywords by search queries by
hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting so there's all sorts
of reports under google ads you just
have to link it up and you link it up
under the admin now there are other
reports that you can look at so if i go
to campaigns i can look at all campaigns
so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say twitter or
instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you run an e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
behavior reports are going to actually
show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website did they come from organic
direct social etc the behavior reports
allow us to actually measure how that
traffic behave once they landed on a
page on our website and so if i go to
overview under behavior now i'm looking
at this graph here it's showing me how
many page views i've had and a page view
is simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here i can
see in this graph how many page views
i've had again over the last 30 days and
if i look further at my overview report
i can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and i can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page i can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so i can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if i click on site
content and i click on all pages then
i'm going to look at a report by page
this is my dimension this is what i'm
measuring my page and now i can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other pages then every page that user
looks at is going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to a to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where page uses accumulation of how many
times the page was viewed in the same
session so in other words you're always
going to have more page views than
unique pages okay so this gives me a
sense of how my page is performed so
again i can look at total page views and
then engagement so ideally what you want
to do with a report like this is if a
user is not engaging on the page then
that should tell you something about the
page itself if they're not engaging if
the bounce rate's high if the time on
page is low if the exit percentage of
exit rate is high then you probably want
to do something with that page now these
are all pages but if i jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here i can
see under my landing page report i can
see the home page had 36 000 17 sessions
in the last 30 days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here i
can see 71 were new sessions meaning
that i had a lot of new users who landed
on the home page in fact 25 000 or 52
of the people who landed on the home
page were new i could see the balance
rates about 42 percent but of those who
didn't bounce they went on to look at
about 4.5 pages per session and spent
about three minutes on the site and the
one thing i like about the landing page
report is i can also see whether that
particular page in this case the home
page did it help contribute to a goal or
conversion and in this case i can see of
those 36 000 sessions i had 22
transactions totaling 1200 in revenue
and that's an e-commerce conversion rate
of 0.06
so the home page over the last 30 days
contributed to
0.06
of the revenue so this gives you an idea
of when somebody lands on your website
and they land on a page is that page
helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under behavior including site
speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed's
important because what google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled 2 835 page
views and of that sample they came back
and said the average page load time is
about 4 seconds now ideally you want to
keep it as quick as possible i would say
even under three seconds okay now there
are other factors involved with page
load time the browser you're using the
country that you're actually browsing
that page from might not have the best
infrastructure you name may not even be
on the best internet network meaning
you're on a cell network or the wi-fi is
not that great or you can be on a page
that just has a lot of images or a lot
of code that may slow it down so there
are other factors involved and so what
google analytics does is show you what
those factors are so here i can see by
browser what the average load time is if
i want to look at country i could see
what country is contributing to the low
time now the great thing about the site
speed report is if i go to speed
suggestions okay what speed suggestions
is going to do is it's going to show me
the page load time by page and then it's
actually going to provide a link where i
can actually click on to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example i can look at this particular
page here this google redesign shop by
brand slash youtube page line number
five if i look at line number five i can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if i click on seven total
what it's actually gonna do it's gonna
open up a new window and it's going to
open up another google report called
page speed insights and page speed
insights is going to give me some
information about what i can do to
create
correct the page load of that particular
page so look at this site speed report
it's important because there is a
correlation between site speed or page
load time and user behavior of that page
and there's also correlation between
page load time and a page ranking
organically on search so page load times
very important it's so important that
i'm even going to save it so i'm going
to click save and click on speed site
speed suggestions as my name and click
ok and now that report is going to be
saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section and
in google analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your google analytics view and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and under the view you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types and analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if i
look here i could see i have pages per
session set at 10. so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case i can see
here
that the goal is set to this particular
page here and so when somebody actually
lands on that page it's going to count
as a goal now there are two other goal
types we can look at one is duration so
just like pages per session in our
previous example if somebody looked at
10 pages per session it's going to count
as a goal with duration it's based on
time so in this particular case if you
set up a duration goal and the duration
is set to say one minute and 30 seconds
then that means if a user comes to my
website and they spend at least one
minute and 30 seconds then it's going to
count as a goal okay and then the fourth
type of goal in google analytics is an
event-based goal so when you set up
event tracking you could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on say
the submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so anytime somebody fires this
event it's gonna count as a goal so you
have four different goal types in google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if i look at goals overview i can be
able to see how many total goal
completions i've had so if i want to
look at it by goal i can just choose the
goal option here so if i want to look at
for example
goal 2 engaged users this was the pages
per session i can see that i had a
conversion rate of 10
meaning that i had 7 000 of all the
users who came to the website 7 000 gold
completions meaning 7106
users looked at 10 pages or more on my
website and so that's how you want to be
able to measure whether users wherever
they're coming from whoever they are
whatever pages they look at you want to
be able to look at the conversion
reports to see if they're actually
converting based on the goals you've set
up whether that's pages per session
duration destination or event goal
conversion tracking reports can help you
measure
who is actually converting and the great
thing about google analytics here is
that i can actually see
by segment so the default segment in a
segment is just looking at a specific
user set so the default segment is
always all users however i can choose a
different segment so if i want to choose
instead of all users if i want to choose
mobile traffic i can select mobile
traffic hit apply so i'm actually now
looking at a subset of data i'm looking
at mobile traffic so if all the mobile
users have come to my site i can see
1400 engaged or looked at ten pages or
more okay and that's a seven percent
conversion rate so the great thing about
google analytics is you have the
opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segment of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report i like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if i click on
multi-channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here i can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if i look at
three channels direct organic and
referral i can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
i look at direct and referral 12 and a
half percent if i look at direct and
organic 12.24
so i can see how different channels work
together and so if i look at top
conversion paths as an example i can
actually see
what channels how channels work together
to drive the conversion so in this
example i can see over the last 30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
times two meaning that somebody came to
the website directly meaning they typed
in the url in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then convert it so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure
if that channel actually did contribute
at a later point and in this case we
could see organic search drove traffic
that didn't convert but that traffic
came back a second time via direct and
did convert so that's our second best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance we're gonna jump into google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical applications so
goals are important goals uh let me just
say this goals are in analytics
something that should be aligned with
your business and
we call goals that are aligned with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in google analytics because if
you're using google analytics you want
to measure everything against a goal so
without further ado
let's jump right into google analytics
so if i go to google analytics and i log
in okay what i want to do
is go down to admin click on admin here
and admin will take you to basically a
screen that looks like this where you
have a account column you have your
property column and then you have your
view column now the view column is where
you're going to go to set up goals okay
so every view
in every property has up to 20 goals
okay so by default in analytics you're
going to have at least one view for your
property so if i have a property i'm
going to have at least one view but if i
happen to set up multiple views like you
see here then i know for every view i
set up i have 20 goals to work with so
where are those goals so under the view
i'm going to click on goals and now i
can see i have 20 at my disposal now you
can see here
by clicking on the recording column i
can see i have in this particular
property this particular view i have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're gonna measure everything in
analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so
if i don't no longer want to use a goal
i could simply just turn it off if i
want to continue using it just turn it
on okay it's that simple you could turn
on and off goals so here i already have
five set up so if you want to set up a
new goal the one thing you need to know
in google analytics is in order to set
up a new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level i would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever is in charge of google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so
i have edit permissions i'm going to go
to goals and i want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal do you have an e-commerce site
is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that i'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red cta button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or
reading review downloading something
sharing something you could choose all
of these options here what i normally do
is choose custom 99 of the time i'm just
gonna choose custom it doesn't really
matter if you use the template or not
it's just a template is basically some
free pre-filled configurations but my
recommendation is always just go with
custom you want total control over how
to set up your goal so
we already have in mind what type of
goal we want to set up so for example if
somebody goes to
fill out a form submission and they go
to a thank you page after that well
what's the url of that thank you page we
want to be able to track how many people
go to that page because we know
if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if i go to continue i'm going to name my
goal first so i'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an id so notice this is goal
id 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so 1 through 5 6 through 10 11
through 15 16 through 20 into goal sets
so for example goals 16 through 20 is
part of goal set four and why does
google analytics combine these goals
into different goal sets well because
it's easier to ma measure
and look at data by goal sets so for
example if i jump into any report here
if i go to all traffic channels and i
want to measure how many goals by
channel i can look at it by goal set so
if i have goal set 1 selected then i
know any goal i have active in there
between goal id 1 through goal id 5 i'm
going to be able to see those goals in
goal set 1 and now i'm going to be able
to measure every goal i have active and
goal set one against the channel so if i
choose goal set two whatever goals are
active there goal set three etc notice i
don't have any goals 16 through 20
active that are in goal set four
therefore i don't have that option
available to me so back to admin the
bottom left navigation again goals okay
we want to measure somebody going to the
thank you page we have edit access we're
going to choose custom as our goal set
up we're going to type in a goal name
i'm just going to say thank you okay
this is goal 15. now this is the
important part google analytics has four
different goal types destination
duration pages per session or screens
per session so screens per session is
related to mobile because google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example i'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal url
so for example destination is my choice
i'm going to click continue now this is
where i'm going to put the url so if my
url is just simply thank you.html i can
just go ahead and put thank you.html
or if it's just thank you then i can
just do thank you depends on the website
depends on the uri structure so whatever
that url is that's what you're going to
put in and when you're done you can
verify it so what google analytics does
is actually
will verify over the last seven days if
anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see zero percent conversion rate so
that tells us that if this is the
correct url then we've had zero percent
people go to that page this is just an
example however if you didn't see a
conversion then you might want to make
sure you check the url here that you put
in and if you do see a conversion rate
then you know it's working so google
analytics actually has options so
we're saying thank you is equal to so
the destination url is equal to thank
you or thank you.html or thank you.esp
or whatever that thank you page is okay
you do have options so if you have a
long url you could say begins with and
you could say begins with say thank you
so this is the logic we're going to say
hey if anybody goes to a url that begins
with thank you then count it as a goal
or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a url
that equals two thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option here
regular expression so google analytics
understands the language of regular
expressions so regular express
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to
track so we can always say you know
starts with or ends with so we can you
know use characters like the dollar sign
ends with or begins with so we can
always do that so you can use regular
expressions as well if you're familiar
with regular expressions if you're not
then you don't have to use them but
there are special characters where that
you can insert in that are used as
regular expression so if you're not
familiar with regular expression don't
choose that option you can choose the
other option of equals to or begins with
now note that on all three of these
options i didn't put the domain so if my
domain is ama dashfoundation.org
slash and then thank you i don't need to
put the domain because analytics is
already knows what domain we're tracking
so you don't have to put in the domain
here when you're entering in in this
case the google url so you can omit the
domain so when you put in that url
you know that you have three options to
work with and then you always always
want to verify that goal url you always
want to verify it because if you see
zero percent conversion and in this case
of the last seven days then that should
tell you something either your goal is
not set up correctly or you just don't
have any conversions either way you want
to double check that now when it comes
to the destination url goal you do have
an option here for funnel so if i turn
on funnel then that means i have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if i have a
cart
and i want to be able to check how many
people go in and out of the cart then i
have the option of adding specific pages
as part of the car so we could say you
know step one which is basically cart we
could say step two
is
billing information that could be slash
billing we could see step three is
shipping information slash shipping and
then step four could be you know confirm
and that could be slash confirmation so
whatever your url structure is for your
cart and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a cart basically all i'm doing is
putting a series of steps with urls as
each step and why do i want to do that
because i can then track how many people
go through my funnel that i've created
okay so here i can see this is my funnel
that i've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination url so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step require so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if i turn that off then i'm monitoring
the funnel through each step meaning
that i can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then i'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert okay
google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations and
on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the
value for that goal so that means that
if somebody did go to in this example
slash thank you and convert analytics is
going to count it as a goal and then
assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-e-commerce if you're say a
non-profit like this organization or
your b2b and you want to track some
value then you have that option there so
with the destination url goal you have
the option of adding a funnel with all
goal types you have the option of adding
a value all goal types and we're going
to go through the rest of them you have
the option of verifying that goal so
that's the structure of setting up a
goal destination url is just one goal
type we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination url goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization so based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because i could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here i can see the first
step is the store front page so
over this particular period of time i
had 84 sessions enter the storefront
page so out of those 84 i can see 21
left the storefront page 63 went on to
the next step in the funnel which is the
cart page i can then see 24 people went
on to the cart page directly and five
exited the site altogether okay so that
gave me 87 total and from 87 i saw that
82 went on to the next page with the
next step what analytics does is they
give you a percentage so in the first
step we had 63 move on to the car page
out of 84 that's 75
so from the cart page to the create your
account page we had 94
move on so
we didn't have anybody entering the
create your account page we didn't have
anybody leave the create your account
page so if 82
82 create your account and then we have
82 move on to the payment page so that's
a hundred percent okay we have one exit
so if 81 that proceeded to be on the
payment page which was purchased so 81
of 82 is 98
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75 percent
funnel conversion rate so 75 of the
people who entered in the funnel went on
to purchase okay so don't be confused
with the overall ecommerce conversion
rate so 75 is the funnel conversion rate
the overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45
over this particular period of time why
because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website so
18
of all traffic went on to convert but
those that did go into the funnel 75
converted so
that's a look at the funnel so if you
set up a funnel that's what it's going
to look like you have the option to
measure everything from step one and
beyond or measure as traffic goes in and
out of the funnel so the purpose of this
is we're going to be able to see where
traffic drops off how effective our
funnel is what pages we need to address
in that funnel okay so that's the whole
point of the funnel and the funnel is
available with the destination url goal
so if i go back to admin if i go back to
goals under the view i can actually see
what that funnel looks like so here we
chose regular expression so this is what
the url is okay you can see our funnel
in each of the steps we have set up
notice we're using regular expressions
here and then if we verify this goal we
could see over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination url goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about
is pages per session so if you're not
sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure
is for example if we set the goal to
three pages per session then we're going
to be able to measure
if how many people went to the site and
looked at three pages per session so
let's take a look at that goal so if i
open up the goal here i can see three
pages per session is what we're naming
it so basically what we're asking
analytics to do is anything greater than
two pages which would be three and
beyond count as a goal so if anybody
comes to the site looks at more than two
pages three pages or more then it's
going to count as a goal and so here we
can verify it so if we verify it over
the last seven days we could see a four
point one two percent conversion rate
and that tells me that four percent of
my traffic over the last seven days
looked at at least three pages or more
so you're probably asking yourself well
what number should i put in for the
actual
variable so in this case we see two well
what you want to do is you want to look
at
on average let's just say year to day
you want to make sure you have
statistical significance so you want to
look at a period of time so if you go to
analytics go to audience okay and then
if you go to overview and if i change my
date range to year to date i could see
on average right now i have 1.21
pages per session so that's on average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically
measure
at a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at pages
more
during their session so look at more
pages and so
we want to be able to see what segment
of the audience is looking at more pages
what channels driving traffic that's
looking at more pages what pages are
contributing to more pages per session
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working and then see what's not working
so you can make adjustments the whole
idea behind google analytics is to
improve website performance and so for
average is 1.2
then if we change it to just two it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 i
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and i probably wouldn't choose
two so i'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session
we can measure how long somebody stays
on the website and we could set up a
goal for that so in this case i have a
goal set for one minute 30 seconds so my
goal type is duration so if i click
continue then basically i'm asking
analytics in this case anybody who stays
more than one minute and 30 seconds on
the website count it as a goal and so
before you actually put in the number of
hours minutes and seconds you want to
look at that average so if you go back
to audience overview here i can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here i could see over the last
seven days if i verify this particular
goal i can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stayed greater than
one minute and 30. and so the whole
point is you can hone in because this is
a goal i can go in this is goal okay
this is a goal here
and so i could see that this is goal 13.
so now i can go
to acquisition as an example i can go to
channels as an example since this is a
goal this is gold 13 so that would be in
goal set 3
so i can actually see what channel is
basically driving that goal okay in
other words what channel is driving
traffic that is staying on the side at
least one minute and 30 seconds and so
that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here i can see
we've have a
over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here i could see
for example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here i could see
social media has a 10
so i could see that or people coming
from organic search are staying on the
site longer or they're looking at more
pages than any other channel so
just like duration or destination or any
goal you set up you can measure that
goal against any dimension just because
it's engagement doesn't mean you can't
you absolutely can and so the whole
point of engagement really goals is to
figure out what's driving traffic to the
site but what traffic is engaging so you
want to be able to pinpoint that so you
can improve website performance now the
fourth goal type available
in google analytics is an event so if
you click on new goal you close custom
click continue you have the option to
choose an event so
an event is something that you can
measure on your website that analytics
can't measure by default so if you want
to measure pdf downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link i mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event
then you want to be able to turn that
event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure
a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event
so if i go to for example
this particular website here and i want
to measure how many times
somebody clicks on the donate now button
well if i met i can measure that as an
event so when you set up an event in
analytics you have to actually assign a
category and an action for that event so
that's the first thing you need to do
when you identify an event related goal
first you need to set up the event in
order to set up the event you need to
assign a category an action okay so once
you identify what you want to track as
an event on your website you're actually
going to go in a tag manager or have
your webmaster go into tag manager and
set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
in action and so here you can see
we have this set up our category is
named donate now and our action is click
and that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action click so when you actually do set
up an event you can go into analytics
and
you can test that event so if i go to
the website and i click donate now okay
the reason why i have this as an event
is because i'm taking to
a third party website to handle the
donations so here i can go into
analytics and now i can see a category
is being fired for header donate with
the action click so that's my category
and that's my action so that category in
action is what is firing after somebody
clicks on the donate now button so if i
want to turn this event into a goal i
can easily do that now that i've set up
the event now that i've identified the
category in action i want to go back to
admin and
set up the event with these parameters
in place so just turns out we already
have the goal set up so let's go through
how this goal was set up so first we
chose custom we chose event
we gave it a name so as a best practice
when you actually set up a goal as an
event or turn an event into a goal i
would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals and you're reporting
you know it's an event so i'm going to
click continue
and now that i've actually have set up
the event already in google tag manager
i've given it a category give it an
action okay see here you can see we have
a regular expression set up so anything
with the header donate or donate is
going to fire this goal so over the last
seven days i have a 0.81 conversion rate
okay i could have easily put in
equals two and put in whatever the
action what or the category which is
donate now
or i could have put action equals click
i could have done that as well so let me
show you another example here so if i do
this
custom continue event donate now here's
my goal id
it's going to be an event so all i need
to do is put in the category in action
so donate now and then click so that's
all i have to do and that's my goal so i
can verify it okay to see if anybody's
fired it and basically that's what i
need to do to turn that event into a
goal okay so you need to set up for an
event first you need to identify the
event set it up in google tag manager
which is another platform and once
you've done that
then you have your category in action
once you have your category in action
you're again going to go into analytics
and then simply put in that category and
action into the appropriate fields to
set up your event related goal now all
events don't have to be turned into a
goal if you actually do set up an event
and you're just not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or doesn't align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events
you can always go to overview and
measure your events that way so here you
can see
all of our events that are fired now we
do have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under behavior so the
point i'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is that
category all you need is that action and
so
so one final note on that event related
goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay so
if i have an event set up i can choose
to add a value here or
in google tag manager if i've assigned a
value to that event so if i go back to
the actual event in google tag manager
you can see i have a value set up for
one dollar then i could just go into
analytics and say you know what i
already have the value added so go ahead
and use the value added in google tag
manager okay so i'm going to choose yes
now if i choose no i have the option to
add the value here just like i would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any goal
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
google tag manager just as i've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and
measure any dimension against that
particular goal so here i can see e
newsletter sign ups by channel
i can go into another goal set here i
can see contact form submissions okay i
can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions okay so just know that
you can align a goal against any
dimension so if you have e-commerce you
don't have to set up for goal for that
that's separate but if you want to take
a look at your goals and analytics
on its own you can just go to
conversions goals overview here i can
actually get a good sense of how my
goals are performing over a period of
time so again if i choose for example
year to date now i can see based on the
goals i've set up how many total goal
completion value which takes into
account the value we've added into these
goals okay the total conversion rate and
here i can see it broken down by the
goal i actually have set up and i can
see it by
page or i could see it by source and
media so i could see google organic is
driving the most gold completions then
google cpc direct and then i could see
some others in here as well contributing
to goals now i do want to point your
attention to another report in google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if i go to
assisted conversions i can actually see
what channel in this example
is assisting with the conversions i've
set up and so what do we mean by
assisted conversions well that means
that if a channel let's just say organic
search drove traffic to the website and
that traffic didn't convert when it
arrived at the website and left but it
came back a week later via another
channel let's just say email and when
they came back via email they did
convert during that session well what
analytics does is they give an assist to
organic search because they help drive
the traffic to the website so it's
similar to the game of basketball if i
have the ball and i pass it to my
colleague and my colleagues the one who
scores because they had the ball last
well they get the credit for the point
i.e the conversion but i get an assist
and so analytics works the same way
they're always going to give credit to
the last click or direct conversion but
they will give credits to the channel in
this case that assisted with the
conversion so that's under assisted
conversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if i want to hone
in on say to donate clicks only then i'm
going to be able to see what contributed
to
that particular goal so there's another
report in here top conversion pass that
i think's important so after you set up
your goals you can actually see
what channels in this particular example
help to drive conversions again this is
year to date so i can see all the
different combinations of channels that
work together
to
contribute to a conversion so again i
can choose a specific goal or
i can choose all my goals so those two
reports are under multi-channel
funneling there's also another report
that i think is good that's time lag
meaning how long did it actually take
somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happened on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but i could see i did get some
conversions a day later two days later
etc so you have time lag top conversion
pass assistant conversions they're all
under multi-channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and i'll take you to
the gallery and you'll be able to see
what other goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in google
analytics so welcome and let's get
started so many of you out there have a
website similar to the one i'm looking
at now this is a non-profit that i work
with i'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that
needs to be tracked for example buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or newsletter sign up
or there's a pdf download or
a video that needs to be you know
tracked based on the amount of people
who click on the play button so i mean
all sorts of inter activity on a website
have you ever wondered how to track that
well there is a way to track that
because by default google analytics
can't track
interactivity and engagement on your
website like you probably want to have
your website tracked so if you have
buttons and videos and things of that
nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under behavior top
events you're going to need to set up
event tracking so event tracking
is a two-part process and we're going to
talk about that two-part process the
first part of that is to identify what
you want to track okay so if we go back
to our example website here i'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we gotta donate now bob we
got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event i
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they looked at how long they stayed
on that page what page they left from
more or less their timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate now button okay
so
this donate now button we want to track
now we have a newsletter sign up we have
facebook and and that's fine you could
track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the donate now
button let's focus on the donate now but
then we'll come back and start tracking
these other things but this is what we
want to track to start out with okay so
step one identify what you want to track
now when it comes to tracking events on
a website you want to identify those
events so we did that by choosing this
donate now button now once we identify
what we want to track we need to assign
two parameters
for that event so with event tracking
you have three parameters but one is
actually optional so you have two main
mandatory parameters that you have to
assign to everything you want to track
in your website and that's the category
and then the action so event label or
label is the third parameter but again
that's optional okay so
basically when we identify an event on
our website we want to assign it a
category and an action okay so why do we
want to assign it a category in action
because when we're in analytics under
behavior under events top events we
could see we have different categories
here and we have different actions we
have different labels so if i click on
any one of these dimensions i'm going to
be able to see some of the parameters
i've entered in for previous events i'm
tracking okay so the whole idea is you
want to be able to group different
events together into a category and
assign an action and assign a label to
it that's really what you're doing
you're just grouping and identifying the
events you're trying to track and so in
this case i have this donate now button
sitting in the header okay in fact i
have a lot of things sitting in the
header so
if i wanted to and i want to track all
these buttons i can create a category
called header and then if i track all
these buttons all these buttons can sit
in that same category if i wanted to or
i can create a separate category for
each of these buttons it's up to you how
you organize your categories because
basically all you're doing is giving a
name to what you're trying to track and
the name is equivalent to a category so
in this case the donate now button's
very important i'm just going to call it
category header donate now i need to
give an action to each category and so
in this case i'm just going to say click
because that's what the action is doing
it's it's somebody's taking the action
of clicking now if it's a video and it's
a play button i can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if i
go back into analytics here i can see
some categories and if i click on action
i can see some actions that i've named
now step three so we've identified in
step one what we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
google search for google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically
is what we want to use to set up event
tracking now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so i'm logged in to
the same email address i'm using for
analytics okay so now i'm in tag manager
and i want to set up my event for this
donate now button so what do i need to
do well for every event i want to set up
i need to set up a tag okay so if i go
to tags i can see i already have some
tags set up and some of these are events
and so when you actually set up a tag i
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it ga dash event
dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the donate now button on
our website so we're in google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if i click
on new okay and i click on tag
configuration i'm going to choose google
analytics and then i'm going to choose
event as my track type so we want the
data to show up in google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a pageview we're tracking an
event and so
now remember in step two you identified
what you want to call that category you
identify what you want to call that
action and you have some optional
parameters like label so first things
first header donates the name of our
category and our action is click and if
you want to add in a label
and a value so if you want to assign a
value you can if you want to add in a
label you can okay those are optional so
you just need to focus on category and
action and then the last setting here
that's probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so
this is automatically set to false and
why is it set to false because it's a
non-interaction
no that's false we want this event if
somebody clicks on the header donate to
be an interaction so for example if i
land on this page here and i click on
that donate now button that i'm tracking
as an event and i actually leave the
site because i have my settings set to
false i want that click to be an
interaction
then analytics is not going to count a
bounce if i change it to true so from
false to true then that means it is
going to be a non-interaction
if somebody lands on the page and if
somebody clicks on the button so i don't
want it to be a bounce i want it to be
an interaction so
my advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property id and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one any time that event
fires in analytics it's gonna have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do
to set up the tag in google tag manager
now if somebody else is setting up the
tag for you then again you want to
revert to step two you want to be able
to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label and or
value why because you're the one that's
going to be going into google analytics
and you're the one that's going to have
to go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular act category in
action and or label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case i'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable
for
my label parameter and why do i want to
do that because in tag manager i have
something at my disposal called
variables and variables allow you to see
specifically things that are being
tracked so in this case i choose page
path okay so page path is a url and why
did i choose page path as my variable
for the parameter label because if
somebody does click on the header donate
button and the header donate button on
our website is on every page if i go to
the children's page i'm still going to
see
that header donate button and so for me
i want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hit or donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in google analytics
what page somebody clicked on the header
donate now button and so now if i go
back to
gtm google tag manager i have a category
i have an action and i have a label
which is a variable okay so note that in
google tag manager you have a lot of
different variables at your disposal and
variables are there to help you identify
specifically
what is being tracked so take a look at
all the variables at your disposal in
tag manager in this example i'm using
page path so now once you set up your
tag pretty straightforward again tag
types google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action and or label and or value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for google
analytics which is your property id so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here i'm going to
look at a trigger i've already set up
for this particular event and so if i
click on it i'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links i'm actually
saying hey
google tag manager fire this event when
the click id equals header donate button
now it just so happens that if somebody
did click on this donate now button
they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager i
could have set the trigger to equal
url equal instead of click id i could
have said
url equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my logic for my trigger in this
case i decided to go with the click id
and so in this case that button has an
id associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click id for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when i
actually inspect the element i can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper pane and in the
lower pane i can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if i hone in a
little i could see id equals header dash
donate button so that's the click id
notice there's also a class i could have
set the trigger to equal this class or
again i could have set the trigger to
equal the url or the page that this
button is pointing to i could have
chosen any one of those but i decided to
go with the id so this is the id i chose
and that's the id i have in my trigger
okay so that is what's going to fire
that event so if somebody clicks on a
button that equals header dash donate
dash button it's going to fire that
event which is going to equal category
header donate action click and then the
label is going to be page path so now
that we've set up our event
we want to test to see if it actually
works so there's two ways to go about
testing an event and the first way is
through google analytics so if we go to
google analytics and then we go to real
time okay we can go to events and here
you can see one is already fired so
let's go ahead and go to and test this
and go to the website so if i go here
for example and i click on amagar alumni
okay so if i click on that you can see
i'm under our family and if i click on
that button and go back to analytics and
look at real time i should be able to
see this event fire so if i click on it
i'm going to go to network for good now
if i go back to
analytics here in real time under real
time under events per second i can see
that event firing category equals header
donate the action equals click now if i
click on
the category here i can see the label
the label remember was page path and
here you can see
this event fired on the our family page
which was the page i was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognize the event so it works it fired
and so therefore it's going to show up
under behavior under events you can go
under overview or top events okay and
what am i going to look for in this case
i'm going to look for header donate okay
if i click on header donate as my
category i'm going to be able to see my
action and if i click on action i'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics i'll be able to
see under label
the page that i clicked on that hit or
donate button which is slash our family
okay the second way in which you can
test to see
if an event fires is if you preview so
if i click on preview and tag manager
okay i'm going to go into preview mode
okay and preview mode allows you to see
in analytics and tag manager and on the
website what tags are firing so here i
could see i'm in preview mode now so i'm
going to go to the website
and i'm going to refresh
and in my browser
same browser i'm using for tag manager i
can see the tags that are being fired on
this page already okay because i'm in
preview mode so here i could see
remarketing i could see page views i
could see google optimize i could see
some tags that are already firing on
this page now if i click on this button
here by holding down my shift command
and then click on that button i'll be
able to see that
the tag fired in preview mode there's my
event header donate and i can see it
fired so now i can see it fired in the
preview mode so in addition to google
analytics in preview mode i could see
that that tag is fired and i know that
it's working so there you have you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time and
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a cta button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so
if you set up a tag and it's an event
name it ga event it's that way you can
see in your list of tags in tag manager
what event tracking you have already set
up so when you set up your tag you set
up your trigger your trigger is based on
logic that can be a url it can be a
click id it can be a class id whatever
you want to use to fire that event and
then once you do that you want to test
it you could test it in gtm or you could
test it in google analytics if it
doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing i would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what i
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case and when somebody clicks on
the donate now button in the header you
want to put the tag name in here the
type okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you could
turn those events into goals and that's
as simple as going back into analytics
okay so if i go in analytics and i go to
admin and i go to goals if you set up a
new goal okay all you need to do is
choose custom click continue you're
going to choose event as your goal name
and then from a naming perspective in
google analytics for your goal i would
definitely put event first and then
click on header donate okay so if i
click now continue what is my category
it's equal to header donate my action is
click and so i can verify
to see if this is working and here i can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and i
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal and
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what i would
recommend if the event is equal to
a kpi or business goal or it's of
importance it's something you really
want to measure okay if it's just a
click say on a facebook button i
wouldn't recommend setting that up as a
goal okay so once you've set up your
event you've recorded it in your
spreadsheet it's firing you want to be
able to then go back into behavior back
into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if i choose my date range
here i can just go to year to date so
here i can see my header donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that
somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if i go to the yama
foundation website okay i can click on
that donate now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because
in some cases users may click on the
button more than once in the same
session and so
here i can see total events unique
events and if i added a value to that
event i should be able to see it here so
if i added a dollar as an example to
this particular event because it had 164
unique events i should be able to see
164 as my value but since i see zero
that means that i did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average i have per
event so it's taking into account the
number of or the value the total value
divided by the total number of unique
pageviews or sessions and so because i
don't have value i'm not going to have
average value but here you can see
because value is optional here i can at
least see how many events or how many
clicks i receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if i clicked
on this video as an example i can see
how many people actually started it i
could see the unique and the total
events and if i click on label if i have
a label assigned then i'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form etc so
what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here i could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in google
analytics under behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're gonna go to
analyze the data data studio
so buckle up and let's get going with
some
data studio from google and so the first
thing you'll need is a google account
okay so if you have a google account if
you're able to get into analytics or
google ads then you should be able to
use that same email address to get into
data studio and all you really have to
do is just go to datastudio.google.com
or you could just google data studio and
get the link but if you're using your
same email address you should be able to
get into data studio and when you're in
data studio you'll be able to see
some templates at the top that you can
work with when you're setting up a
report or you'll be able to see some
existing reports that
you have either set up or somebody has
shared with you okay so
here if you just click on shared with me
i'll be able to see all the different
reports that have been shared with me in
the past okay so here if i click on
recent i can see all the reports that
i've recently opened so let's just take
a sneak peek at one of those reports so
if i open up a report that i actually
created then what i'm going to be able
to do is look at some data over a period
of time just like i would if i was in
google analytics okay so the great thing
about data studio here is that it works
just like any google drive document
whether it be a google sheet a google
doc or a google slide okay you could
share the document with anybody you
choose to anybody with a google account
okay or if you just want to share a link
okay you could just click on can view or
edit copy the link and then you can
message that person or email that link
to whomever you want to see this report
okay if you want to invite somebody to
edit it or just view it you can
certainly just type in their name or
email address so that's the great thing
right off the bat with data studio is
it's shareable so if multiple people
have added access to the same report
then multiple people can go ahead and
edit that report even at the same time
so that's the great thing about data
studio we're going to cover a lot of
different benefits to data studio i
definitely like using data studio over
analytics and since we're talking about
the comparing the two this in my opinion
replaces if i go to analytics and i go
to say customization and i go to
dashboards this replaces the old
dashboard reports and if you see here at
the top google's even persuading you to
move over to data studio because
dashboards and custom reports are very
limited in nature whereas data studio
not limited at all okay you basically
are creating reports that suits your
needs so just continuing on with some of
the top level
okay benefits to data studio is if we
like a report we see we can easily just
make a copy of it so all i have to do is
click on that copy and i'm just going to
copy over everything over so i'm going
to copy the data sources or i can change
the data source and basically what we
mean by data source is where is google
pulling the data from now keep in mind
and i'll go over this more specifically
with data studio you can pull pretty
much data sources from anywhere in any
source whether that be a spreadsheet a
database another google product another
platform like facebook you could
certainly pull it from analytics so you
could pull data from any data source so
if you go ahead and make a copy you just
have to make sure you know what data
source you're pulling the data from
because basically all this is is a
report with dimensions and metrics and
those metrics are data points associated
with that dimension so we can certainly
refresh data okay again we can get the
report link just by clicking on the
report link and copying it it's a bit of
a shortener here i can go ahead and
schedule an email delivery so if i want
to go ahead and have this report sent to
somebody i can certainly do that here
and i can have it sent to them either
daily weekly or monthly and then you can
also download the reports if you
download the report okay i can choose
all pages or select specific pages so in
this report i have two pages set up now
in data studio you can have as many
pages as you want okay so here i can
choose just one page okay some
additional options um i can add a link
back to the report i can password
protect the report okay i can ignore the
custom background color if i wanted to
i'm just going to go ahead and download
that and i'm going to download it in pdf
and so when it downloads i'm going to be
able to then you know view this report
or send it off in pdf format and so
those are some of just the top level
features that you have available to you
in data studio now let's take a step
back okay this is if you're just viewing
the report and you want to share it or
download it or send a link to somebody
what if you actually want to create one
so that's what i'm going to walk through
here i'm going to go ahead and create
one now remember we can just go ahead
and copy this if we like it we can copy
it we could choose certainly choose
different sources of data so i'm going
to go ahead and just play around and
choose different sources of data i don't
know exactly what those sources are but
i'm going to go ahead and choose them
anyway then i'm going to go and copy
that report so i copied it and basically
what it's going to give me is a
duplicate of that report except the data
is going to be different because i'm
choosing different data sources okay so
now here we can see the report and it's
going to load up and it's going to load
up with different data sources now if i
don't see any data that means the data
sources i chose don't have any data that
align with those specific metrics and
dimensions and that's exactly what i see
here so what i'm going to have to do is
go ahead
and choose different data source so let
me select a different data source here
i'm going to go ahead and choose that
one
or i can go ahead and create a new data
source so let me just do that so i'm
going to click create new data source
and now
if i don't want to use one that i've
used in the past i can go ahead and
choose from all these different data
sources available to me so there's no
limit on what we can connect so you see
bigquery
sql okay you can see data from google's
marketing platform display video 360.
google analytics google sheets google
search console okay keep scrolling down
basically what data studio does is
partner with third-party products like
super metrics for example so that super
metrics is the intermediary
program that pulls in for example
facebook ads or google my business pulls
it into data studio for you here you can
see adobe analytics okay you have all
sorts of connectors that you can connect
to so i could choose any one of these to
connect it now if i choose one with say
super metrics i'm going to need that
super matrix account now if you choose
any one of these direct google
connectors like i'm going to choose
google analytics then you don't need a
third-party intermediary like super
metrics you can go ahead and based on
the login that you have set up or that
you're using to log into data studio
you're going to be able to see all the
other google analytics accounts you have
access to so i'm just going to go ahead
and choose an account here i'm going to
choose a property
and i'm going to choose my view then i'm
going to click connect okay so that's
how you basically will connect a new
data source now when you actually
connect that data source what's going to
happen is
data studio is going to give you the
option and it's going to give you an
option to make changes to all the
dimensions available dimensions are in
green and if i keep scrolling down i can
have the opportunity to
change any of the metrics metrics in
blue and i can change it to
the type of metric i'm getting whether
it be just a numeric or
a percent okay or i can change it to
aggregate auto i can change it the
description of it okay that's making
changes to something i can even just
delete it or remove it or i can go ahead
and add my own
metric or dimension okay just by
clicking on add in a field and so here
i'm going to go ahead and choose some
available fields or put in my own
formula so this is kind of that first
step when you create your
source or your second step if you will
your first is actually choosing the
source in this case we chose google
analytics the second step is
having the opportunity to change out or
edit or add dimensions and metrics now
if you're a novice or beginner to data
studio then i would say let's skip this
step uh if you're not comfortable
editing or adding dimensions and metrics
and go ahead and just skip it and click
on this blue
call to action add to report okay so i'm
going to add it to the report and now
that it's been added now i'm still
seeing no data why am i seeing donated
so if you copy report you don't see any
data chances are it probably has a
filter because i copied it and here you
can see i have a filter so i'm just
going to go ahead and remove the filter
and voila i see data so that's something
you need to be aware of when you
actually copy over an existing report
you have to choose the
data source but keep in mind when you
copy over an existing report you're also
copying over filters and segments so if
you're familiar with google analytics
you know that in google analytics if i
go back into analytics here and let's
just say i go to
acquisition
and i go to
uh all traffic and i go to channels what
do i have the opportunity to do in these
standard reports well i have an
opportunity to add a segment i also have
an opportunity to add a table filter
you could do the same thing in data
studio okay because i copied the report
basically i copied over all of those
filters table filters and segments that
go along with it and so you just need to
be cognos of that as you're building out
this report now that's if i copied it so
you can see i copied it and everything
else that goes along with it the the
color scheme the
the logo etc now this is if you not
familiar with data studio it's good to
copy report play around with it etc
that's probably what i would recommend
so again if you're not familiar with
daystar you want to get comfortable then
go ahead and even choose one of the
templates if you don't have access to an
existing report so let's go ahead and
just choose i'm going to say one of
these templates that data studio has
provided okay you can see looks pretty
good layout looks pretty clean i got all
my important metrics in here what's
going to happen is if i want to use it
i'm going to click use template now same
thing
that occurred when i copied a previous
report i'm going to have to choose a
data source so i don't want to choose
google analytics
sampling of data or sample set of data i
want to choose some actual data so i'm
going to have to go in and choose an
existing i can choose an existing data
source here or i can connect to a new
data source okay so let's go ahead and
just choose one of these data sources i
already have access to and i'm going to
go ahead and copy this template so it
works in the the same way as if i copied
an existing report i'm just copying a
template okay so here you can see i'm
copying the template now okay the only
thing that's missing here is the ability
for me to edit the dimensions of metrics
so if you any time you add a new data
source you're always going to be
prompted to
have the ability to edit dimensions and
metrics if you don't if you're not
comfortable with that then just go ahead
and add the data source just like i've
done here and so now i could see
basically the same report i could just
see it's just pulling in data from a
different data source that's all now i'm
in edit mode okay so if i want to view
the report just as anybody else would
view it if you gave them a link to view
it i'm going to click on this view
button here and so now i can see i have
some drop downs here and so this drop
down is basically allowing me to choose
my own analytics account if i wanted to
so i can go ahead and just choose any
one of these if i want to change the
data here i get another pull down and
this is my date range selector so i can
change the date range if i want to do so
if i change the date range then the date
is going to change now if i want to edit
anything here in this report i'm going
to have to go back and click on the edit
mode so just click on the edit button
there and now i'm going to be able to go
in and edit this existing template now
i've already established a data source
but i could change the data source if i
want to all i have to do is just go here
click on any one of these tables or
metrics
and change out the data source just by
clicking on this icon here okay where it
says edit data source so i'm going to
have the ability to
make changes
to any of the dimensions and metrics or
i can just get rid of that data source
and choose a new data source now in data
studio you have the option to change the
layout you have the option to change the
theme so you can go from a simple theme
to say a simply dark theme you could
change any aspect of the report if you
want to so just know that anytime you
click on any of the data points you have
the same options available you have a
chance to edit the data or you have a
chance to style it so when we talk about
styling you know you can basically
add labels you can hide labels you can
compact the numbers you can style it any
way you want based on the particular
table and so that's the great thing
about data studio is really really
customized to what you need so for
example here what are the top countries
by sessions well
i don't have to show legend if i don't
want so i'm just going to get rid of the
legend i can change the font okay i can
change the color scheme on it i can go
ahead and do a lot of different things
here so once i've made changes after i
view it i'll be able to see those
changes in full effect okay so just know
that in data studio whatever report
you're looking at that you have edit
access to you have the ability to make
changes to anything in that report now
here you can see
i see a lot of different data great what
i can actually do too is add a page and
so let's go ahead and click on add a
page and now we have two pages to our
report and now i have a blank canvas on
page two so now what do i want to put on
page two well the best practice to me is
organizing your data okay so just like
in analytics analytics organizes their
data between audience acquisition
behavior and conversions as a best
practice that's probably what i would do
here maybe stick all your mobile on one
page or your acquisition on one page all
your maybe your organic search on one
page now it's okay to have a summary
page just like we have on page one but
if you're going to have multiple pages
then perhaps think about organizing it
based on the multiple pages that you add
so here let's go to page two blank
canvas so the great thing about data
studio again it's just very easy to
start populating okay so i'm gonna go
ahead and click add a chart okay which
type of chart do i want to add well in
the spirit of visualization you probably
always want to choose something visual
start with an easy pie chart here i'm
going to go ahead and select pie chart
and i'm going to place it to where i
want okay now i can go ahead and
increase the size if i want to make it
smaller make it bigger etc voila i have
a pie chart now if i want to edit this
pie chart again i have my options
available i have my data and i have my
style so i know it's pulling from this
data source here okay i want to change
my dimension dimension is what we're
measuring so let's just maybe change it
to source
and maybe i want to go from page views
to let's just say
goal conversions so i can just go in and
start typing in the metric and
here i can see gold conversion rate
let's choose that okay now i can see
source by go conversion rate now if i
don't want source let's change that back
to default channel grouping so now my
dimension is default channel grouping by
goal conversion rate so now if i'm
looking at my data i could see that
referral has a 51.8 percent goal
conversion rate followed up by organic
search with 19.5 okay so again it's very
easy
to
edit the data points on any chart now if
i want to style it i'm just going to
click on style here i can go with a
single color
dimension values okay i can slice it up
in different colors i can choose a
background color i can add a border
customization is really endless here i
can change it from 10 to say 12 slices
if it's available maybe go down to
the top three it's as easy as it gets i
mean it really is fairly intuitive to
use you just got to learn what
dimensions and metrics you want to use
now i have my pie chart the great thing
about data studio just like powerpoint
for example i can go ahead and just copy
this pie chart command c then command v
and voila i now have a copy of it okay
well uh maybe i don't want two pie
charts so let me go ahead and change one
so i can go ahead my upper right here
and go from say a pie chart to let's
just say a trend line if it makes sense
or maybe
a combo chart so i have my sessions
along my goal conversion rate now i can
again go ahead and change that i don't
want sessions maybe i want you know go
completions or something so let's go
ahead and add that in there goal
completions so now i can see goal
completions and then go conversion rate
by my default channel grouping so again
i could style it you know if i don't
want red bars i can go ahead and choose
a different bar okay it's really that
simple now if you find you're running
out of real estate okay you can always
scroll down and change the height so if
i change it from 1200 to fall to 1800
pixels i can get more real estate to
work with likewise on the width so now i
can make it really wide to work with now
when you make those changes to the page
you're probably going to see the same
effect happen on page one in fact you
will so back to page two okay so if we
go to page two here what we could do is
go ahead and add more charts or we can
copy and paste existing charts and go
ahead and change them up okay just by
command c and command v now what you
want to do if you create more pages here
is maybe add in your date range so if i
go click on my date range symbol here
i'm just going to drag and drop that
enlarge it a bit now i can make a
default date range i can say i want to
show data for this month so anytime
somebody goes to the page the data that
shows is going to be for the month the
month to date now again if you want to
customize it what you can do
is you can just copy and paste so ctrl c
or command c
go back to page two command v so this
gives you the ability to just start
customizing now the one drawback to
data studio being a little bit nitpicky
is in powerpoint if you're copying from
slide to slide it tends to paste it in
the same exact location i know it sounds
a little bit nitpicky but in data studio
when you copy and paste something it
doesn't necessarily
always paste in the exact location so
i've noticed that uh being the issue but
it's a small issue nonetheless so you
have the ability to copy an existing
report you have the ability to go ahead
and
choose an existing template and like i
said going back to data studio you have
the ability to just start with a blank
canvas so again just walking you through
the steps here blank report brand new
canvas i need to choose a data source so
you can see existing data sources if you
don't have existing data sources to
choose from you can always just click
create new data source okay when you
create new data source you're going to
choose from a list if you're new to data
studio start with something easy like
google analytics if you choose google
sheets then great you're going to be
asked to look for data in google sheets
likewise with google ads if you choose
google ads you're going to have to
choose a google ads account so start
easy start with google analytics okay
i'm gonna choose analytics i'm gonna
choose my account my property i'm gonna
choose my view i'm gonna go ahead and
connect because this is a new data
source i have the ability to go ahead
and edit my existing dimensions and
metrics if i want i don't have to then
i'm going to go ahead and click add to
report it's going to confirm the
connection to the data source now i have
my connection to my data source i am
free to start doing what i need to do to
the report whether that be get somebody
else involved immediately by sharing it
with them go ahead and start adding
pages and organizing it you know adding
my date range adding a logo adding a
logo simply just clicking on image
selecting my file or my images it's a
best practice anytime you
create a table i would go ahead and put
a text box above it maybe put a title so
you could say
channel in this case channel by
conversion rate okay so let's make that
a little bit bigger as a best practice
that's what i would do now it's you're
free to do whatever you in data studio
the whole point of data studio is really
to customize the report any way you want
and what i mean by customize is adding
the dimensions and metrics that are
important to you and so data studio
gives you the opportunity to copy an
existing report or again you can use
existing template or start with a blank
report the options are all there for you
data studio is fairly easy to use again
you could share it okay you can download
it you can schedule emails you can send
a link to people okay there's really no
limit to what you can do with data
studio okay again you can rearrange
things add pages organize them add
filters add segments i mean basically
anything you can do in analytics you can
do in data studio a lot more features my
recommendation to get started you know
go ahead and choose that blank canvas
and just start playing just start
playing by adding charts okay once you
add charts okay the data is going to
populate and again you're just then free
to start playing around with dimensions
and metrics so that's the way to get
started with data studio practice makes
perfect
once you get more comfortable then
you're gonna have full-fledged reports
to work from just like i use for my
clients there's no limit on what you can
do and what you can see and again
customization makes the report look good
obviously the data and improved data is
going to make your report look good as
well so keep all those things in mind
apply some of the best practices but
more importantly play around get
comfortable and then eventually you're
going to start using data studio as your
main source of data over google
analytics welcome to foundations of
digital analytics my name is stefan
amell i'm a consultant i'm a teacher i'm
a speaker and i've been in the field for
several years so in this training which
is part of digital marketing
uh we're gonna we're gonna look at what
are the essential
components and the essential knowledge
that you should learn about being a good
digital analyst so we're not going to
deep dive into how to use the tools but
we're going to learn a lot about what
are the concepts what are the essential
elements of being a good digital analyst
so
stay along with me and we're going to go
through various sessions addressing each
of the topics that are important in the
field
welcome to introduction to digital
analytics so we're going to start with
basic concepts
supporting the the role of the digital
analyst
so imagine in the offline world imagine
you have a store where you are able to
look at people you know walking on the
street looking at the window of your uh
shop and
looking at you know what are the
characteristics of those people why are
some people coming in the store and some
people not coming in why are
how people interact in the store what
they are looking at how they walk in the
always uh in the uh looking at different
products
maybe picking something looking at it
and putting it back on the shelf
even putting stuff in their cart and
eventually abandoning the cart and not
purchasing anything
so in the offline world doing something
like this would be you know fairly
difficult and expensive and would be
time consuming
in the online world we have the
we're lucky because we have a constant
environment where we can watch learn and
adjust and improve our business to
better answer the needs of our customers
so this in a way is the essence of what
is digital analytics is to understand
where people are coming from what are
their characteristics what are they
doing on our website
and whether it works for them and it
works for us because we want to have a
successful business
so in the past just as a side note in
the past we were talking about web
analytics because it was very very
focused on websites and it was heavily
geared toward marketing
and now we're talking about digital
analytics so we've broadened the scope
and when we talk about digital analytics
we talk about websites of course but we
also talk about mobile application we
talk about the internet of things where
we can measure any type of device and
collect data about whether it's working
or it's not working
and we've broadened the scope from a
business perspective because we're
thinking about marketing but we're also
expanding to every business function
we're looking at sales we're looking at
customer support
we're even looking at hr because most
websites have a way of contacting to
apply for a job for example so we've
broadened the scope from web analytics
to digital analytics
so what do we want to learn
we want to have some some very uh
important understanding of what it is to
be an analyst what it is to do digital
analytics
we want to understand what is the
context of the business and how being
creative is also an important part of
the analyst role
we want to
understand how we evolved from looking
at simple reports
up to today where the landscape is is
very complex
very rich
and there's virtually no limit to to
what we can do
so why digital analytics so i just alert
to
the physical store
but
one of the element is the the ex
despite all of the experience that you
might have
it is very uh useful
it is valuable
but it doesn't scale so your experience
is is your own career path and you can't
easily tell other people you know here's
everything i've learned so through
digital analytics we can more easily
expand the capabilities of understanding
how things are working
um
assumptions
you you have you can make an assumption
and it might be very very valuable it
might be very plausible that yes i think
doing this on the website would be
better for our customers and and better
for our business
but until you you actually test it until
you actually make the change
there's no way to be
sure that's
effectively better than the other
alternative
so assumptions are good but we want to
go in
at a pace where things are moving so
quickly that we have to adapt and we
have to evolve very quickly and last is
faith
fate is yeah we can believe that
something is so good we can believe that
the latest technology and latest trend
is so awesome
but at the same time
we have our own bias we are biased in so
many ways because of our experience
because of our culture because of uh the
the previous jobs that we had in the
past and so many reasons so
through digital analytics we
remove in a way this bias that we have
so those are you know three
aspects of why you should go for digital
analytics experience that doesn't scale
assumptions that can't be proven until
you actually do it and and faith and
bias that we have that we want to get
put that aside and go with something
that really works
so continuing on why
do we want to do digital analytics
in in today's environment we have a
tremendous amount of data
data is coming from everywhere it's
coming from your website it's coming
from your mobile application it's coming
from from your own business systems like
customer relationship management crm
systems it's coming from sales it's
coming from competitors it's coming from
all over the place so the problem is not
having a large amount of data because we
usually have more than we need
but we want to
extract information out of it
information is being able to understand
the meaning of the data but once we have
information what do we do with it
we want to transform it into knowledge
knowledge is understand the context of
the data and the context of the
information we have so we know that for
example if we if i have a piece of data
that says
99.9
okay that's a piece of data that i have
but
what does it mean information might be
that 99.9
is the percentage of successful
transactions so there's a little number
of transaction that actually doesn't go
through
through my systems and there are errors
and stuff knowledge might be that
understanding that because i'm in a
banking environment
99.9 is actually below
the threshold of acceptable transactions
that i should process at every time so
in most uh environment you will see
targets of being able to train to
process every transaction transaction
with a very very little amount of error
so 99 point maybe 99.95
so i'm just a little bit below my
threshold
this is knowledge
i know because of the environment that
i'm in i know because of the target that
i have that i need to do something and
wisdom
is actually being able to act on that
information
now that i know
what can i do with it i need to
investigate i need to find where the
problem is i need to be creative and
find
different alternatives to try to go from
99.9 success to my target of 99.95
percent of success okay so going from
data
up to
acting on the data
this is
critical in the role the analyst is
going to play
so it's if you don't want it we
sometimes we hear the term reporting
monkey reporting monkey is is pretty
negative you know it basically means
that yes you are able to extract the
data you might be able to turn it into
information in the form of reports but
you don't bring the knowledge
so you don't want to be reporting monkey
right
so you know being a teacher and being in
the field for so many years uh i looked
at how people define what is analytics
and you know
simply put analytics is the science of
analysis
okay what is analysis
analysis is it really relates to a
science it's how we break something
complex
into small parts
little chunks so that we can understand
how they work individually and if we
understand how they work individually we
can measure them and we can
optimize them
so this is really what is analysis
breaking something complex into smaller
parts so that we can understand it and
therefore we can optimize
so
again what is analytics the science of
analysis
that's a very simple definition right
but after asking you know fellow
colleagues and other consultants and
practitioners and a lot of people
basically
i realized that there were no
good definition of what is analytics
so i decided to come up with a
definition i i think can hold water very
easily
so i define analytics as being how an
organization arrives at an optimal and
realistic decision
informed by data
every single word is important here
how an organization might be a company a
private organ company it might be you
know publicly traded might be government
nonprofit so it's an organization so it
applies to any type of environment
how you do something implies there's a
process there's a way to do it there's
some kind of recipe that you can follow
to
get to a success
the optimal in real estate is really
important because it plays on the
ability of the digital analyst to be to
be creative to to find the balance
between what would be the best solution
if there were no constraints if there if
there were no limits to what i can do no
constraints of budgets no constraints of
politics maybe no constraints of the
legal and ethical environment
and i could do anything
so this would be the optimal but
realistically
there are a number of things that i need
to consider so i need to find a balance
between what would be the best solution
and what realistically i can do and and
this also is key for the digital analyst
because
oftentimes analysts will make
recommendations that don't go anywhere
and the reason for that you very often
the reason is simply that analysts are
not able to make recommendations that
are both optimal and realistic so we
need to find a balance and informed
decision implies action and then formed
by data implies that uh there's still we
still leave room
for
the
human brain to make a decision to
leverage their own expertise experience
and other other
elements that come into play when you
have to make a decision so that's why we
say it's informed it's not automatically
done with the data
later on we're going to talk about
automations and stuff like that
basically what happened is we delegate
that responsibility and we automate the
process but at the beginning there's
still
a an informed decision to do it right
there are three essential elements
that we need
i mentioned
the banking environment the financial
environment so we need to understand the
context of the business
we need we need to have data right
and on top of that we need to be
creative so there's a lot of room for
creativity in what we do being creative
creative is is the ability to go beyond
the obvious it's the ability to go
beyond the here's the top 10 things that
you should do and be and go beyond that
you be much better than that
being creative is being able to
do better than your competitor because
it's easy to look at the competitor and
say oh we're going to do the same no you
don't want to do the same you want to do
better than that so context data and
creativity are the three important
elements that will allow us to do our
analytics
at the core
of the analyst role when you think of it
we are essentially change agents
we bring change to the organization and
that's why we make recommendations
uh we push for change and sometimes yes
it might be difficult
but again going back to the definition
of what is analytics we need to balance
the optimal and realistic so if we
we are good change agents we're going to
be able to make recommendations that
that get acted on right
and being a change agent means that
sometimes it won't work
it will take time
it will imply you know
facing you know changes
about status quo
we want things to change we want to
improve things we want to take risks if
we don't take any risks
nothing is going to
the big difference i've seen between an
analyst and a manager is essentially
that the analyst has a power of
recommendation
but the manager has a power of decision
so the is in in in the future we're
going to see more managers who are more
data savvy and data driven
or data informed
and we're going to see that they have
both the
skills to be
really leveraging data in all contexts
of the business
but also make the decisions and in the
analyst role
you make recommendation but you
typically don't make the decision except
in the
scope of what you are responsible for so
for example
if you are responsible to
optimize adwords campaigns
on google
on google search
you've been delegated that
responsibility and you are you you make
the improvement you make the measurement
and you make the decision to reallocate
the budgets and optimize those campaigns
because that power of decision has been
delegated to you but typically
when we go beyond those boundaries we
have a power recommendation no power of
decision
so
is it hard or easy that has been a
debate for the past 10 years
i would say you know it's it's really
easy to start it's really affordable to
start there are free solutions that you
can use and get going very easily
the
key to make it easier
is to work on the thing that you can
manage that you can control and that you
can influence and we're going to talk
more about those things manage control
and influence this is how you're gonna
keep your work interesting and easy
and
in the next lesson we're gonna talk
about the concept of maturity so we're
finding out what are our strengths and
weaknesses
and based on that develop a roadmap that
will be optimal and realistic so that we
can do better digital analytics
so in this lesson
we've looked at
some very important aspects to get going
and we're going to deep dive into each
of those aspects a little more in the
upcoming lessons
we need context we need data and we need
to be creative
we need
to
understand how we can break something
complex into smaller parts so that we
can understand it and we can optimize it
we need to understand also that
we went from web analytics
web focus and marketing centric to
digital analytics where we can leverage
any
data we have
and we can basically optimize any aspect
of the business given we understand the
context and we can leverage the data
we also
want to
emphasize the importance
of working especially when you're
starting in the field
work on the things that you can control
manage and influence
and lastly doing a maturity assessment
will allow you to identify your
strengths and weaknesses
and develop a roadmap that will
work for you
over the next six months year and then
repeat the process of
accessing your maturity and adjusting
the world map accordingly
in the past web analytics and not
digital analytics but web analytics was
defined as the measurement collection
analysis and reporting of internet data
for the purpose of understanding and
optimizing web usage so as we saw in the
first lesson it's important to
go
beyond this restrictive definition of
what is web analytics and embrace
digital analytics there are still
components of
data collection
measurement
analysis
reporting and visualization so but the
difference is that we're not web-centric
we're not marketing-centric we want to
use the right data in the right context
to inform business decisions
so today's the role of digital analysts
is quite different we are change agents
as i mentioned
because we
know how to make sense of the data we
want to
bring it to life and be able to
convey an understanding
of what is possible
so by breaking
something complex into smaller parts
again we can also understand the
constraints and what is possible
given the specifics of your
organizational
environment so in this lesson we're
going to learn about the digital
analytics maturity model which is a
concept that i've created years and
years ago as a way to assess
your organization's trends and
weaknesses your capabilities over
various key areas of maturity
so this is how we're going to look at
people processing technology but with a
broader
understanding of what are the factors
that will help you succeed in digital
analytics
so
there are a couple of famous
guidelines i would say and one of them
came from avinash kaushik a number of
years ago
it's called the 1090 rule
what it stated was that if you have only
a hundred dollar to spend on digital
analytics ten dollars should be spent on
the tools and ninety dollars should be
spent on the people using those tools
and you know be it 10 90 or 20 80 the
concept is that people are more
important than the tools and the great
thing is in this course
you are developing your skills as an
analyst you're going to be able to apply
that regardless of the tool so your
value in the market is going to increase
so analysts are
you know we can extract data from the
tools there are tools that will spit out
a number of
interesting data and interesting reports
but without an analyst to really
understand what is going on
you won't be able to provide valuable
insight things that the business will
care about
so not just data data is easy to get at
a certain point information is
relatively easy to get also but
you need to go beyond that you need to
understand the business you need to
be able to provide actionable insight
another example of a guideline
again put forth by avinash kaushik is
the 2080 rule about the work of an
analyst
so ideally
we would like to
spend a very little amount of time doing
just reporting because reporting is
typically available out of the box from
a tool and
frankly anyone can go in a tool look at
the numbers and make up their own mind
the analyst brings a lot more value
because of the unique skills of the
analyst to be able to bring context to
the data
the sad reality and it's true in digital
analytics it's true in business
intelligence and other fields we spend a
lot of time
getting the data ready and
very little time doing real analysis
work
so
maybe it looks more like this where you
do some reporting but
you should also spend time doing
looking at the various acquisition
strategies looking at understanding
customer experience looking at is
staying plugged into the context
you know understanding the business the
evolution of the business but it could
also be understanding the evolution of
our industry the digital analytics
industry and knowing that there are new
tools and concepts out there that could
be useful for your analysis
exploring new strategic options to
influence the business and of course you
need some breaks and lunch in those
times so maybe the part missing here is
the sad reality that you could have
another circle that would go around
around this one that would be about
getting the proper tags on the site to
collect the right information also
transforming and preparing all of the
data so you can actually do analysis
so
what are the some of the mistakes that
we see most often when it comes to
digital analytics one of those is
failing to understand the
issue of integration the data collection
itself the tagging as we call it or
integrating data from the website with
other data source it takes a lot of time
it is complex failing to realize the
limits of unstructured data or we could
even
just say fail to realize the limits of
data in the first place the different
tools have different ways of collecting
the data they have different meanings so
you could even end up with two metrics
that are very similar but somewhat
different because one come from a social
media source the other one comes from a
different tool and you try to match
those numbers and they simply don't
match
a third mistake is to assume that
correlation has any meaning to explain
something and it's easy to
find correlation where there's actually
no relationship no meaning it's easy to
fall into some kind of self-fulfilling
prophecy where
we
seek the data that will justify or
satisfy our hypothesis instead of the
other way around
and then underestimating the labor
skills needed
we often
get told that such and such tool are
going to make the job super easy and
anyone can do it and so on but it's not
always true yes some tools can make our
job easier
but certainly not easy
and as the
tools gets better
the expectation the complexity of what
we have to work with is
increasing
faster
so there's always a lot of demand in the
market for people with the right talent
to leverage data
the team and expertise of course is
super important it's not about
knowing how to use a specific tool but
it's about being smart being intelligent
being able to exercise judgment
and
be able to apply those skills in the way
that you're going to analyze data
so the team and expertise represent is
quickly represented by the way
the skills are structured within the
organization so how does your
organization structure its data and
analytics resource and team
so maybe there's no dedicated resources
maybe there's a project team again is a
challenge because the project is
eventually going to end and those people
assigned to the project are going to go
back to their business doing something
else
or maybe it's just a part-time analyst
and that's a challenge because
the
field of expertise is so complex that
working on your own
part-time is very difficult so it's
getting better when you have a full-time
analyst a distributed team so different
skill sets but reporting the different
managers
while at level four you have a
multi-disciplinary team of people
working for the same single manager
and at level five you reach a point
where your business stakeholders
your users are empowered they know how
to get to the information they need and
they understand what it mean and they
can make decisions on their own
area number four is by far the weakest
spot so there are some benchmark data
about the digital analytics maturity
levels of different organizations
and by far it's always the weakest spot
so
we want to be able to have a methodology
in place a process in place so that when
we do something we know the recipe
so compare that to a cookbook you can
follow the cookbook but it won't make
you a master chef
here we want to be able to do is to
identify problems and opportunities
develop hypotheses and eyes and provide
insights if you don't have any
methodology
every time you have to do an analysis
you start from scratch you don't know
how to do it
maybe over time you've defined your own
way so first time you do an analysis of
your campaign performance on google
search
maybe it's a little bit more difficult
but over time you know that oh if i have
to do it again this is how i do it
it's good but the problem is
if you go on vacation or if you leave
the organization there's no
that knowledge is lost
maybe as a team as a group of people
working together maybe you have defined
your own methodology again it's that bad
every time you someone new comes to the
team you have to train them there's a
learning curve
while at level three if you use a proven
methodology and in this course i'm going
to show you
one way one proven methodology that can
be used to do analytics the benefit is
there are probably training books
resources that you can leverage
even courses that you're going to be
able when you hire someone to say
knowledge of such and such methodology
is the criteria for this job
at number four you are agile
but for online tasks for example
it is very likely that your website has
been developed
with agile development concepts in mind
but how is it that once the website is
live we want to do analysis and we don't
use an agile methodology to do our
analysis that doesn't make sense
but the rest of the organization maybe
is not as agile as the web environment
or the digital environment so that's why
at level five the whole organization is
agile be it for offline or online
processes
so there's quick evolution quick
adaptation of the environment and how to
leverage that it's important to note
that agile doesn't necessarily mean
agile development as in developing
websites
there's important aspect of agile
management which is a philosophy of
management
so the
agile methodology that we're going to
use is called lean six sigma
and it has a couple of
easy to understand improvement steps
that we can go through
it's uh the benefit of linseed sigma
it's a well-defined set of practice
aiming at
eliminating defects
so it used a lot of segmentation of data
slicing and dicing of the data
looking at it in different ways if you
like
it is perfect for as a continuous
improvement process when the environment
is changing and evolving quickly
but it also has an in in its mindset the
fact that it's a collaborative team
effort that will lead to success so
let's look at what are the dmaic
improvement cycle so we start with
define
measure analyze improve and control
so the dmaic acronym is define measure
analyze improve and control
so we're going to be able to look into
the details of each of those steps but
briefly what we mean here is you start
by defining what is the problem you're
trying to solve what is the opportunity
you're trying to capture
what data is available and if it's not
available what how would i collect it
analyze we want to find correlations and
patterns in the data
in order to understand what's going on
and in the improved phase we want to be
creative in order to provide
recommendations that are
both meaningful
relevant appropriate
given the context
and control is once we've done those
changes
we want to make sure that we've actually
achieved a sustainable improvement we
want to come back to it and make sure
that yes indeed we did some we improved
the outcomes
so
the goal here is you might have seen
information in the past about sigma and
there's there are caveats there are ways
of using sigma in different ways and
they have different training levels you
can be a green belt or a black belt a
bit like in karate but the precepts or
the concepts of sigma are pretty simple
it has the user in mind all the time
you want to deliver consistent quality
it is data driven you want to increase
velocity and velocity is improving the
speed at which you deliver value to the
organization so imagine it through the
dmaic cycle imagine that you reduce the
time between the moment you find a
problem on your website
a problem in the user experience
you find that problem
and you reduce the time between the
moment you find a problem the moment you
solve the problem you've just increased
velocity you're
providing additional value faster to the
organization
sigma or lenses sigma also provides a
lot of tools and a good framework to get
going quickly and it allows you to
quantify the complexity of what's going
on
so all of that
readily applied to our environment so
it's it's really fascinating that to see
that lenses sigma or c sigma was
developed maybe 20 years ago and apply
in an environment for manufacturing but
we can readily leverage this expertise
that was developed over time and apply
it in our field so we don't have to
reinvent the wheel
the last dimension is the tools
technology and data integration and
interestingly enough this is probably
the one that has the least influence of
on your ability to be successful with
analytics so
we have this great saying do not put
your faith in what statistics say until
you have carefully considered what they
do not say
so i don't mind which tool you are using
or how big your big data is that's not
what is really important you can green
you can have a lot of insight with small
data and simple tools
it's all a matter of balancing all the
aspects
of your digital analytics practice
so the questions are
it's not about which tool you are using
it's about this level of sophistication
in the way you are using those tools so
maybe you don't have a tool that would
be the lowest level
maybe you have out-of-the-box solution
like click stream analytics basic
instrumentation basic implementation of
google analytics for example at level
two you have defined clear outcomes kpis
and dashboards level three you are using
segmentation
you are applying merchandising concepts
if you are an e-commerce website you do
a b testing a campaign optimization you
have defined personas kpi alerts
so all of that maybe if you are not
familiar with that terminology those are
all things that we're going to cover
during the course
at level 4 you use multiplicity so
multiple data source in order to gain a
better understanding of what's going on
you might be merging different marketing
data source doing multi-value testing
behavioral targeting that would be an
indication of greater maturity
and at level 5 you use crm data and data
about your customer with marketing you
might be doing predictive analytics
and evaluating the lifetime value of
your customers so this requires a more
sophisticated understanding of digital
analytics or analytics concepts
there was a global organization in the
gaming industry they decided to group
their 20 stakeholders
including analysts managers and business
stakeholders and do an internal
mini conference where everyone would be
presenting a little something on what
they are working on
so what we did is we did a maturity
assessment
individually so we asked everyone to
fill out a survey
for those who are managing analytics
their perception was that
everything was pretty well advanced
pretty high level of maturity
all pretty well balanced
except the expertise and they recognize
that they were trying to hire more
people in the team and that's why their
expertise was lacking a little bit
so very strong
very good level
when we look at who is responsible so
those are typically the analysts
themselves
the picture was quite different the
picture was that most of the aspects
were low interestingly enough expertise
was at the same level
process was pretty high and technology
was very high but governance and
objectives were very very low compared
to the perception of the managers
so right there we see that there's a big
disconnect between
the perception of capabilities from one
group the managers
to the other the people who are actually
doing the analysis
and technology isn't an issue it's
actually higher than what the manager
felt because the analysts were saying
we've got all the tools we need that's
not an issue
and process was also fairly high
but then this came out those informed
people are their business stakeholders
and
they are typically the product managers
of the games one of the comment was
really really clear it said something
like
i get all those great reports
and they are very interesting and i get
recommendations
but
i don't understand how they got there
therefore i don't really trust it
so we see just through this simple
maturity assessment involving different
stakeholders we see that the perception
of capabilities was very different so
what what is the solution to a scenario
like this the solution was to for the
managers to sit down with their analysts
and really explain this is why what you
do is so important this is how it's
going to be used this is how the
stakeholders are going to be
making decisions based on your data
based on your the information and the
insight you provide and based on the
recommendations you provide
this was a great way to engage the
conversation and then decide what is the
action plan
that we want to do in order to
identify what is the expertise they need
do they need to hire someone new junior
or senior do they need maybe someone
external just for a short time and hire
a consultant and so on do maybe what
they needed actually is not someone new
maybe what they needed is training in a
specific area so that they become more
efficient
so again the solution to that was not a
technical solution
it was just about communication and
change management
so do they need more training maybe yes
maybe no what kind of skills they should
develop and should they hire someone
with those skills already or just train
people to about those skills
do they need temporary help or someone
that will have a
will be on boarded full-time what can
they do to educate and engage their
stakeholders so that they have a greater
trust in the data in the information
recommendations and so on
so let's see
how we have three different areas of
skills that we need to understand in
order to be successful as an analyst
the first one is the business outcomes
and actions the second aspect is the
enabling capabilities and the third one
is analysis so let's look in at each of
those those aspects
so it starts with a strategy and some
goals that are communicated as business
requirements and objectives to people
who understand
the technological capabilities and
constraints of the various technologies
that you're using
if you're building a website it's
different from building a mobile
application it's different from doing
advertising on mo on social media and so
on so those are the unique
characteristics of the technologies that
you are using people those people tends
to have a good understanding of the
information architecture what are the
functional components on your website
how to do tagging and how what is the
structure and what data is available so
those are more technical skills
but what they do is they make it
possible they enable you to have
the means the tools and the data
so that someone with more of a
statistical background problem-solving
approach someone who's able to sanitize
a lot of information a lot of data into
something meaningful
and communicate effectively back to
the stakeholder and communicate
actionable insight and recommendations
so when you think of it
think about you think about what is your
strength in which area are you the
strongest is it on business side is it
on the more enabling technology side of
things is it more in statistics and
effective communication and things like
that so typically every one of us we
have one
strength one very strong area we have an
area that we can manage we're okay with
that we can get along with it and the
third one usually is something that
either we're not interested or we're not
skilled at doing so this reinforces the
importance of working as a team finding
other people who will be able to augment
your ability to have an empowered
analytics team and deliver more value to
the organization if you are a consultant
consultant often
do implementation
of
digital analytics solutions so they are
in the enabling capabilities area and
their clients
usually know a lot more about the
business than they do which is perfectly
fine so right there it applies also to
a consultant versus client relationship
where the consultant is there to augment
the capabilities in some of those areas
but certainly not replace all of them
as a reinforcement of the fact that
analysts are changing agents
there's really one big difference
between an analyst and a manager
the analyst has the privilege of making
recommendation
but typically no power of decision
imagine
that you are
the manager
and
the analyst comes with the
recommendation you've made would you say
yes to that
if as the analyst you wouldn't say yes
to your own recommendation it's
obviously not a good one you need to go
back to the drawing board
what are the qualities of a good digital
analytics leader
you have to have a breadth of
understanding you have to be able to
translate business requirements into
creative useful meaningful solutions
a good analyst is someone who who asks
questions they they don't go with the
obvious they want to go beyond that
they have an ability to understand what
are the needs of their stakeholders and
propose the right solutions
but they also need to have a depth of
knowledge they need to
have some
specialist area
be it you know technical skills or be
a depth of understanding into
a specific business like automotive
industry so
you have different
knowledge in different business
disciplines are going to be very
important
so think of the depth and breadth of
knowledge so the ability to operate
across different
disciplines is going to be important so
are you someone who
statistics or are you someone who
understands statistics for the
automotive industry for example
that's different so breadth versus depth
of knowledge but obviously again you
won't be able to master everything
so depth of knowledge versus breadth of
understanding and here in this course
we want to expand your breadth of
understanding of the concepts of digital
analytics to so that you're going to be
able to apply those concepts
in the specific vertical industry with
the specific tools so that will be the
depth of knowledge
so focus is another aspect you need to
be able to make abstraction of what is
irrelevant and focus on what is really
meaningful for your analysis
sometimes we see that in analysis where
it's going a little bit all over the
place and eventually come up with a
conclusion that is not really
well tied to the analysis process that
just went on
you are detail-oriented oftentimes
motivation is what really excites you
about analytics in one way we can
consider that
for example everybody knows how to use
excel to do spreadsheets about anything
you can be an expert at using excel and
being build absolutely amazing
spreadsheets or you could be someone who
knows about budgeting and create a
simple budget in excel so you don't have
to be an expert at the tool in order to
leverage it so which way are you is it
more
the trill of
leveraging a technical tool to do
something absolutely amazing or is it
using the tool for
simplifying your work from a business
standpoint
so you can look at what excites you
about analytics what do you think is
going to be the next big thing in this
industry
sometimes
you don't have to do analytics all the
time
you have to understand the concepts so
that if you need you're going to be able
to find the right resources to help you
out
so there's some useful
tools that you can leverage the digital
analytics association has for its
members only it has a tool that allows
you to do an assessment
of your
professional career and provides you
with some guidelines on how to improve
so just the fact that you're taking this
course is already a very good indication
of your desire and ability to expand
your horizon and learn more about
digital analytics so keep going
a couple of key takeaways success
depends greatly on the digital maturity
of your organization but also of your
own
skills
you want to identify and find
what are your strengths and weaknesses
you want to balance the various areas of
success
and you want to reap the maximum
benefits before you try to move on to
the next level
the framework of the digital analytics
maturity model will help you communicate
or start a conversation
i think if there's one key element you
need to remember and we'll
get back to that is the define measure
analyze improve control cycle this is
going to be very useful
and it's preferable to do small
incremental improvement with using agile
concepts rather than trying to change
big things and take big risks that can
easily fail
the your own skills and the team
structure if you remember the t-shaped
breath and death aspect i think is going
to guide you in what are your interests
and what skills you you want to develop
over time hi this is avinash and welcome
to the next edition of our web analytics
videos this one's on a
topic that is near and dear to
everyone's heart and its creep
performance indicators um i don't think
that uh
you can go very far in web analytics
without hearing the name kpis uh
brandished about in all its excitement
and glory and yet
i think that uh for the most part people
um are a bit confused about what kpis
are how to select them how to make them
more actionable what value do they add
and
and all of those other wonderful kinds
of things and so in this video we're
going to do two two parts of this video
and um it's going to be my attempt to
start at the sort of the ground floor
and explain from the from the very
beginning what what these things are and
how do you
understand and study these animals
called kpis and how can you how can you
avoid some of the pitfalls that um that
sort of befall many of the
other people and get your own web
analytics journey off to a flying start
so
this is going to be a lot of fun and
regardless of what role you have
regardless of whether you work on the
seo side of things or ppc pr
online email marketing
just or traditional website analysis i
really think that these two videos are
going to be very important and relevant
to
pretty much any persona that touches
your website
so i hope that you're going to have fun
and let's get going
um the very first thing that i wanted to
sort of cover is uh set a baseline for
what a kpi is and of course when in
doubt there's only one place we can all
go and that's the great wikipedia so
obviously wikipedia has a wonderful
entry for key performance indicator and
their definition of kpi is actually a
good one and it states that kpis are
financial and non-financial metrics used
to help an organization
define and measure progress towards an
organizational goal so a bit bit high in
mighty you know and and glorious perhaps
but nonetheless a really really nice
definition of what a kpi means again
regardless of
um what channel you apply to it and
regardless what persona is going to end
up using it and and to me i think that
if you step back from the definition
i was joking with
john marshall that you know kpis are
are like heartbeat is is a kpi that that
i can measure using a stethoscope and um
i put you against your heart and i can
see if you're alive or dead you know the
beating of the heart is is the kpi that
indicates
uh something very critical about your
body you know another kpi is the
temperature of your body that i could
take using a thermometer and in this
case the kpi gives a different
sort of read and it tells me if you're
feeling well or you're running a
temperature and if you're running a
temperature how high is it and do we
need to just take an aspirin or call a
fire brigade to put off you know your
your 1010 temperature well at that
temperature you probably need other
health but regardless
so in its simplest terms i i encourage
you to think of kpis as as those kinds
of indicators that sometimes tell you
something is drastically wrong in the
case of the heartbeat or at other times
can help us understand some interesting
things about um about the process that
you're measuring and um of course i i
had to sort of come up with my own
definition you know and to me i i hope
that that you'll you'll agree that this
is sort of a very simple easy to
understand metric and balances two very
important things and and the definition
is kpis are measures that help you
understand how you're doing against your
objectives and then really these two
things are very important there's two
words at the end the very first one is
measures and the other one is objectives
and i really do believe
that objectives are very critical to
understand before you go on a kpi
hunting mission so so so keep that in
mind you know measures that help you
understand how you're doing against your
objectives are are is exactly what i
think kpis are key performance
indicators and let me give you a couple
examples you know make sure let's have
some fun and and
understand couple of kpis that may not
be top of your mind and and uh further
sort of make this concept more concrete
and here's here's a great example of
course there's a kpi library on the web
you know surprise surprise um
and then here's a really great kpi uh
percent of
nasocommerce infections and and the way
that the kfi is defined i think is very
much along the definition we've just
proposed and it is how many inpatients
acquire infections inside the hospital
you see see there it's it's a measure
very clearly defined and tied to an
objective which is that people coming
into the hospital with no infections of
any kind should not get infected once
they're in the hospital so absolutely a
glorious wonderful example of what a kpi
is and here's another one we were doing
a webinar and and of course um
much to my delight there were a number
of kpis that i could see
in in the dashboard that was presented
right here and and the one that i
thought was most beautiful and
delightful was
attentive the percent of people who were
on the webinar at that given moment in
time who were paying attention to what i
was saying this is a very very good
metric it's a clear measure tied to our
objective that we're giving a webinar
and everybody should be paying attention
it's a really wonderful metric again
another one that's not totally tied to
our daily web jobs but nonetheless makes
the concept concrete and
let me give you a last example of a kpi
and a lot of people don't think about
this when they're measuring websites but
i really love it this is a kpi that's
actually used by blinds.com
and daniel is the cmo over there shared
this data with me and his kpi is gross
margin per visitor so he really measures
this hardcore for people who come visit
his website and and over time as you can
see over the course of two years nearly
two years the kpi has gone up and to the
right again measuring the outcome which
is improving the gross margin
for every single website visitor clearly
defined kpi that that daniel is
measuring much to the success of
blinds.com so those are just three
examples that hopefully help you make
the definition more concrete but let's
actually before we dive too deep into
other examples of kpis that you could
use and you should be using for your web
business let me walk you through four
distinct attributes of a great kpi
before we get into too many examples and
and this is sort of
a test that i encourage you to apply
every time you go out there and choose a
kpi for your business
and the very first very but very very
very critical one is i think great kpis
are uncomplex
and let me let me let me help you
understand that i i run into things all
the time where i i saw this kpi
engagement quote unquote engagement kpi
and and essentially had seven variables
some were multiplied divided by the
other ones and and some were to the
power of something else and at the end
of these six or seven variables a number
was spit out and it was so
complex that there's just no one except
the creator of the kpi who could
understand what it actually meant or
what the number that got spit out meant
but worse than that the other problem
with this kpi was that if even if the
number got spit out and you understood
what the definition was there's just no
way on god's green earth they can
understand which of those variables over
the root cause was
of of things happening well or not
happening well in fact most of the time
some of the variables were up the other
were the other way down and the number
that got spit out was essentially flat
so you could wrongly assume that
everything was great with the business
when in reality it was not the case at
all so
i strongly encourage you when you pick
kpis to make them uncomplex because if
you're the only person is the creator
who understands what the kpis what
definition of what it's measuring then
it is highly unlikely in today's
distributed complex organizations where
we're trying to create data democracy
that you'll succeed in your mission of
making your
company data driven and use that kpi it
is highly likely that complex kpis
essentially become auto deleted when you
send them out and nobody can understand
or take action from them so try not to
be cute at least initially and create
metrics that are uncomplex because in
the end what you're solving for is an
organization to use the kpi to take
action and not just you yourself so this
is great first
test that you should apply
and the second one is kpi should be
relevant there is this there is this
belief today that best practices work
for everyone there even our books
recommending kpi saying oh here's a
cookie cutter mechanism if you are a a
seller of widgets or you're a social
network or you're you're you're you're
um
you know a blog then here are the kpis
that you should use and and that's it
and you should not worry about anything
don't hurt your pretty little brain and
just copy paste these and and happy
birthday to you and and this really is
not true in my experience i find that
kpis are very unique to each business
and the objectives of each business
remember our definition measures is the
first word objectives is the last word
in fact to me best buy and circuit city
make a great case where essentially on
the surface both of these businesses are
exactly the same they sell electronics
pretty much exactly same electronics
look at the look at the top navigation
bar
in fact for both of these businesses and
there essentially could be a copy paste
of each other and yet
when you think about the objectives of
what these businesses are solving for
they each have an extremely different
business strategy online circuit city is
heavily heavily into getting people to
come to their stores look at look at the
free shipping on orders
25 and up and ch or choose 24 minute
in-store pickup then there's nothing
about sort of store pickup right there
in the header so circuit city's core
strategy let's drive people to the store
best buy score strategy let's get people
to buy online and yes we do have an
option to pick and store but that's not
really the core strategy so go back and
try and understand what you're solving
for in your business and it's okay to
take inspiration from others but if you
simply copy-paste metrics
then it is highly likely that they might
not be relevant to you and you won't be
able to make as much progress in your
business as you could possibly
want to have happen so remember that
kpis should be relevant to your business
the third one is that the third awesome
rule is they should be timely
very very important i was doing a job
interview with a with a company a couple
years ago and and i asked them you know
how come your performance in the last
quarter was uh actually spectacular you
made a ton of money and what they said
to me is ah yes yes we would like to
understand that we've just executed the
query that will help us understand
what's happening with that metric
increased revenue and that query will
return its results in two months i'm not
even joking
admittedly this is a big business but if
the answer to your kpi takes two months
to find it's highly unlikely that you
would be able to take action that you
need
remember the web moves at a pace of
light and it's very important that the
metrics you create at least most of them
not all of them but most of them are
available in a timely fashion so if you
want to make decisions on a weekly basis
then creating kpis that take a week to
collect is highly unlikely that you
would have time left over to find
insights and take action so remember to
apply the test that kpis should be
available to you be able to be computed
and available to you in a timely fashion
and in in
time enough so that you can then look at
the kpi and then further spend some time
understanding analyzing segmenting it so
you can take action on it so timeliness
is very important
the last rule is they should be
instantly useful um and this this rule
is because i've seen so
many kpis they just want to make me cry
because i they just it takes like 10
minutes to explain what they are and and
they and there's really no way that we
can make everyone understand what the
numbers are showing um and they're not
really instantly useful and here's a
great example of what i mean by
instantly useful this is a report from
click tracks one of my favorite tools
and as soon as you look at this report
it's not a data puke of the top keywords
that are driving traffic to my website
what it is showing me are the keywords
that are statistically more significant
now and are actually sending me
sending me more traffic over the time
period i'm analyzing or less traffic in
the time period that i was analyzing so
as soon as i look at this report
immediately i can take some action
and this is really what i recommend that
your kpis be on your dashboard your
senior decision maker should be able to
look at your core kpis and and just by
looking at the numbers whether up or
down or flat they should be able to
sort of understand at least some
semblance of of what kind of success is
being driven um from those kpis or lack
thereof so look for kpis that are
instantly useful rather than uh kpis
that show up on a dashboard and and then
it takes you two and a half years to
understand um you know if what what what
what trends were or or in order to make
them more useful so so that's another uh
important rule that i have so let me
give you an example of a kpi that sort
of meets all four of these rules and my
my hope is that as you go about your own
business you'll apply these rules to the
kpis that you have
so to close this video i want to walk
you through some examples of what i
think are great kpis
that are that i think
have some universal appeal to most
businesses that exist out there but what
i also want to do in this part is
actually
encourage you to think beyond your
standard click stream stuff if you've
seen the other videos or read my blog or
book or anything that you've read market
motive i'm sure that you'll know that
i'm a big fan of use of web analytics
2.0 concept and this idea of using
multiple sources and and i think this is
a big mistake people analysts and
marketers make on the web where we don't
use multiple sources to create kpis so
let's get going and let me exceed some
ideas in your mind that you can build on
there
and of course the first most obvious kpi
in the world in the universe is
conversion rate and
it's highly likely that it is
relevant for your business and then you
know
traditionally what we think of
conversion rate is you know e-commerce
did you know what's my conversion rate
and that's the graph you see on the left
here it's 1.41 for this website and then
you know am i making revenue in this
case 5 000 euros so
very traditional metric applies
everywhere so
you measure conversion rate
look at the absolute value and it's very
very useful
but the other thing i want to tell you
quickly before we go to the next one is
think of conversion rate as having many
many different
kinds of outcomes that you could measure
it could be lead submitted it could be
something that was viewed on your
website it could be of course e-commerce
for retailers so think of conversion
rate more broadly but of course for
e-commerce websites this is exactly what
you want to measure
and the next one is is one that i think
is a hidden api that i think that many
people don't measure which is called
average order value um and this is a
wonderful wonderful kpi and and in this
particular e-commerce website you can
see the average order value is
345 dollars and this is really a great
kpi because
it's great to know that you had 1.41
conversion rate but you know over time
measuring average voter value could tell
you if you're much better able to sell
uh products and services on your website
or if you are merchandising and
upselling and cross-selling and
promotional efforts that you have are
having the kind of impact on
what people end up buying on your
website so remember you could have a one
point four two converge percent
conversion rate for for for months and
months and your average order value
could consistently be going down the
toilet or keep increasing so another
different way of understanding if as
with each visitor who places an order on
your website are you doing a great job
of upselling cross-selling promotions or
or helping people find the products and
services they need so i love this kpi
average order value because it gives me
another diagnostic measure for
effectiveness of my website
um and then these are two of my favorite
measures also on the e-commerce realm
but it could be used for non-e-commerce
websites as well and they are called
days and visits to purchase
i'm sort of on the record as saying that
most marketers and website experiences
are created um with this uh the concept
of one night stands in their mind where
you know you just come to my website and
and buy right away in this session and
it said you know nobody sleeps on the
first date and that's really not how the
web works either
people come to your website explore it
have the dance you know maybe go out for
dinner with you and put something to
your cart and then go away think some
more play hard to get and maybe on the
third time they actually buy something
on your website so
days and visits to a purchase are great
kpi because they help you understand
true customer behavior on your website
so in this case on this website you'll
notice about 45
of the people buy on the first visit but
then the rest of the people actually buy
on subsequent visits in fact about four
percent traffic buys uh after nine to 14
visits and so this is a great way to
understand customer behavior on your
website but then also help you
understand and segment your data so you
can understand okay what kinds of people
do buy in the first place what products
are they buying and then what are these
people taking multiple visits to go buy
what campaigns are driving them
what products do they buy and and and
why is it that they buy after many
visits so it gets you great
understanding of customer experience but
more than that helps you evolve beyond
the one night stand mindset that so many
marketers unfortunately have on the web
and these two visits is the corollary of
that you know you could have 10 visits
in one day and this sort of frames it up
as how many days does it take and this
data is actually for a travel website uh
actual data for a travel website and and
there's nothing more toxic you know in
terms of nuclear decay then airline
tickets they become expensive with every
passing minute and yet on this travel
website
where that sells airline tickets
only 60 of the people bought on the same
day in fact almost 40 percent of the
people this big block of people at the
bottom actually bought between eight
days to 120 days later this is
astonishing so these people
made a known choice to pro pay a very
expensive price for the ticket rather
than buy it on the same day and save a
ton of money and it's very important
that you understand um you know why do
these people do this and what
destinations are they going to and and
can i do something like help these
people save their itineraries or ping
them and send them an email reminder
that the price just went up another 10
bucks so i can get them to come back
sooner and buy from me so
this is a great kpi that gives you a
peek into the customer's mind and gives
you ton of actionable insight to improve
your websites i love love these two
metrics days and visits to purchase
and here's a great place where i
measured this particular metric and in
this case i segmented by different kinds
of
acquisition strategy pay-per-click
direct as well as affiliates and you'll
notice that different people behave
differently so people who come into
pay-per-click actually take greater a
lot of them take greater than three
click three visits to buy while my
affiliate people who i'd actually
thought would need a lot more convincing
to buy in my website 64 of them buy on
the first visit and this is exactly what
i meant by the power of this metric to
give you a great peek into the
customer's mind and then go back and
optimize your affiliate marketing
campaigns in this case actually because
i did not think the affiliate marketers
marketing campaigns convert fast my
landing page did not have actually so
right away add to cart buttons and
things and right as soon as i got this
boom i put a lot of calls to action on
that um those landing pages so
excellent action on my website right
away improvement in conversion rates so
very good kpi
and
two other kpis if your website is not
e-commerce related is loyalty and
recency so um for example i'm i use the
new york times website and let's assume
for a second it has no ads or the bbc
website which also has no ads and it's
pure content website no car e-commerce
of any sort no lead submissions nothing
just content and in that case i like
measuring visitor loyalty which is how
frequently do people visit our website
and it's not just measuring average
visits to in a month and that's really a
average metric that really lies and does
not give you good data
look at the distribution some kpis you
have to look distributions
and in this case i would go back to my
cmo and say look
39 of the people came once to my website
even though in this case average visits
to in a month were just two
but there were about four another thirty
forty percent of the traffic right here
at the very bottom that visited my
content website between nine and two
hundred times a month so it's amazing
this bucket of really loyal people to my
website and they're coming again and
again and again every day actually on
the bc website this is me i go there all
day long again and again
being a political junkie um and and you
can understand these you can you can
create a goal around this to say month
over month for our visitor loyalty
distribution kpi are we getting better
or worse so in this case actually we got
slightly
worse in july because the number of
people who only visited once uh went up
from 61
to 64 so so that's a great way to
measure success by using metrics like
visitor loyalty for non-e-commerce
websites and here's another one called
visitor recency so let's say you're
running a social networking application
where the only purpose of your
application is so people friend each
other and send applications and do super
poke and other annoying things
nonetheless you you don't have an
e-commerce model yet
or any advertising model to speak of how
do you measure success
of this particular business what measure
recency are you actually creating such a
sticky and engaging websites that people
come to it every single day they can't
wait to get to it
and in this case what the metric and
data shows is that 66
of the visitors to this particular
social networking website actually
visited it less than zero days ago it's
phenomenal because
they can just go back to their
executives and say look our application
is still sticky so engaging microsoft
why don't you give us a 400 million
dollar investment for one percent stake
in our company because we are so awesome
well they can use this metric to do that
because indeed 66 of the traffic these
are the people who have nothing better
to do than send their spend their lives
super poking other people and sending
them applications a phenomenally
actionable kpi for a non-e-commerce
business that helps you measure the
health of the business and if they're
successful in their strategy so really
wonderful metric
and the next one i wanted to share with
you it comes from a survey-based
mechanism and it's called task
completion rate and i'm a big fan of
this metric because on any average
website you probably have two percent
conversion rate what is everybody else
doing how do you measure success of the
98 of the people who are not converting
on your website and i really like this
metric task completion rate and
essentially it helps you understand get
beyond the obsession of this thin blue
line at the very bottom you know that's
your two percent conversion rate and
help you understand what's happening
this big red the 98 of the people and if
your website has delivered any value to
them it's a great kpi measured using
surveys and essentially what it is is
the answer to the question were you able
to complete the task on our website
whatever task you were there for you
could be there for e-commerce submitting
lead donating money to our presidential
candidate
read the latest news download a bio
apply for a job look at market motive
videos
be convinced of our greatness doesn't
really matter why you came to the
website task completion rate gives the
power of the customers when they leave
the power to the customer so when they
leave the website at the end of the
visit we can show them a short survey
and say why were you here that helps us
understand primary purpose and the
second question is were you able to
complete your task so in this case if i
was running this website
i know that 74 of the people converted
uh sorry were able to complete their
task then my job is to figure out what
the other 26 were doing and why they
were not able to complete the task so
this is a great way to measure success
of every single person who's on your
website and and i mentioned in my past
market motive videos that i've teamed up
with iperceptions to create this survey
for free that anybody in the world can
use totally free and on exit when people
exit your website it shows the survey
and ask helps you measure task
completion rate across different primary
purposes and it's a very very actionable
metric because rather than you and me
john and michael and i sitting around
arguing about what should we fix next on
the market motive website we can simply
take the content of this survey the
answers from our questions when they
tell us what tasks they're not able to
complete and use that as an input to
improve our website so we're not only
solving for our egos inside the company
but we're solving for our customers on
our website so really great way to
measure task completion rate using this
free survey and in turn improve
i'm sorry improving customer
satisfaction because
if you were able to complete your task
your satisfaction in this piece of data
is 77 but if you were not able to
complete a task your satisfaction
dropped dramatically uh and and you can
help influence and improve that and the
for q survey will help you understand
why people are coming
here are the reasons in the blue and and
what each of those people's task
completion rate is so you can identify
things you should be fixing so in this
case clearly the people who were not
able to complete their task
a bunch of them were there to buy and
and only 39 were able to complete the
task which essentially is a crime
against humanity because this is an
e-commerce website and everybody should
be able to buy who's there to buy so
boom right away you understand why
conversion rate is
0.0001 percent
real actionable insights
uh and i believe this is the last
example i wanted to take you out of your
website and help you understand uh your
performance in context of your
competitors and and my last kpi uses
competitive intelligence in order to
understand
your performance and i love this metric
called share of search
and it's essentially like what what
traditional marketers have been using
and they tend to call it share of shelf
so when i mean walmart or or you know
i'm at procter gamble brand manager i
really want to know what my share of
shelf is for pantene shampoo in in in
walmart and target and all these other
kinds of stores well why not create such
a metric for the ultimate shelf in the
world which is a search engine
essentially google microsoft yahoo that
dominate acquisition strategies for most
websites and to how much a share of that
shelf do i have when people are looking
for me and you can use competitive
intelligence tools to understand that so
in this case i can say okay what are the
top key websites that send me traffic
how much share do i have of search
traffic
so for singular from google yahoo
microsoft all these other engines and in
the case of singular it's nine point
three three percent uh traffic they have
share of traffic from google while
verizon it's actually ten point six
percent uh from google so verizon gets a
lot more traffic from google than does
singular so in this context singular you
know would cry a little bit because uh
every percent of difference here on this
report is hundreds and thousands of
searchers so really
a singular can get can create this kpi
and track it not only track it as a
point in time which is what you're
seeing on your screen but actually
measure trends over time to and in this
case you'll notice verizon is the blue
line and singular is the orange line and
for some reason singular has been on the
right path over months and months so
their nine percent traffic from google
is great because they keep increasing
over time um while if you look at
verizon
they have started to make big mistakes
and started to literally drop off the
radar in this case for the last few
months a very very troubling development
if i was verizon and if i was singular
this kpi share of search would
immediately get me a big bonus uh from
my boss so this is a great way to
measure success by using a metric that's
available externally and and as we give
you another example of google insights
for search i wanted to see how much
brand impact i'm having how much share
of searches uh top of mind i am in terms
of my customers
when i look for laptops so um i said you
know i like thinkpads a lot i have an
x61 which i'm very very fond of
and i wanted to know if thinkpad is do
how thinkpad the brand is doing over the
last few years compares to latitude
which is the brand of dell macbook air
which is the brand of apple of course
and vaio which is the brand of sony and
and try to use this kpi which is the the
search the number of queries at a search
engine to measure if my brand dollars
being spent online and offline are
causing people to look for my laptop my
brand of laptop and unfortunately what
it turns out is both dell and
thinkpad have been going um down
over time and that's precipitously in
some case and that's sort of very very
sad and what it shows is um
macbook air when it's launched boom ton
of people ton of interest
totally beat the heck out of both uh
latitude and thinkpad and yet now uh
it's sort of uh mr steve jobs is coming
down to earth a little bit more uh over
the last few months but but notice the
green line that's the sony vaio and and
then they've done a marvelous job of
having a nice upward slope over the last
four years and consistently doing the
kinds of things that are required to
stay top of mind in customers and and
have lots and lots of search queries be
generated and create demand for their
products so again a great kpi if i were
sony uh wires brand manager to show
value that my ad dollars are creating uh
in the general ecosystem while everybody
else is going down i am going up so
another wonderful kpi um that you can
create from competitive intelligence
data why do you need to do web analytics
if you're doing anything on the web for
the longest amount of time we have made
very
faith-based decisions when it comes to
our marketing our customer service our
are
advertising and other kinds of
activities that companies do and a lot
of it was dictated by the fact that we
didn't actually have access to a lot of
data
it was or it was very difficult to get
data but one of the coolest things about
the web is that you actually have access
to near infinite amounts of data
usually not for a lot and
so one of the reasons that you want to
use web analytics for is that
the simple act of of adding a tag to
your website allows you to have access
to an enormous amount of consumer
behavior when it comes to your digital
existence that means that you get a
really deep understanding of what is
working what is not working what do
consumers like what don't they like
where do they come from where do they
not come from and other kinds of things
and it allows your company to make very
smart decisions for example if somebody
walks into a chevy dealership
here in santa cruz you probably have
very little idea about what caused that
person to come to the chevy dealership
but if somebody lands on chevy.com on
the other hand
they bring with them a lot of trace of
what caused them to come and engage with
you
for example they might have searched on
google for a particular keyword and now
you have access to that insight or they
might have come in response to
television commercial that you ran and
visit your website and you have access
to that so a lot of this is
a really great way to understand
effectiveness of how you spend your
money which in turn helps you
do very smart things when it comes to
your consumers
not only that but it also opens the mind
of your organization much wider maybe
you believe that the only thing you can
do on the chevy website is give
information that drives people to the
dealer but in reality people who will
engage with you online are going to be
there not only to
go figure out where the nearest dealer
is but they could be existing customers
looking for help or it could be car
enthusiasts who want to customize their
cars and trick them out is play around
um for and configure a car they might
want to buy six nine months from now or
they might just be people who want to
understand a lot more about chevrolet's
philanthropic efforts and at the moment
all of these things are very difficult
to be met in an offline world but with
online you can and that's where web
analytics plays a really key role
helping you understand why people come
to your website once they are there what
is it that they do and at the end of it
do they leave happy and did you make
money both of those questions get
answered very quickly
so now that you're very excited about
web analytics let me formally define
what web analytics actually is and in my
books the way that i have defined web
analytics is it's the analysis of
qualitative and quantitative data about
your website and your competition to
drive continuous improvement about your
digital presence your customer needs and
prospects which translates into great
and fabulous desired outcomes both
online and offline for your business
that's more of a formal definition of
web analytics and let me let me sort of
cover a couple of these pieces that are
really really important and the very
first one is very often web analytics is
mistakenly believed to be just the art
of logging into google analytics or
adobe web trends or ibm and analyzing
all the quantitative data you have
related to the clicks
and that is indeed a big component of
what analytics is all about but it's
also about answering the question about
why people do what they do and that's
where sort of qualitative analysis
around surveys and usability tests and
those things come into equation one of
the cool things about the web is not
only can you analyze your own
performance we can actually analyze how
your competitors are doing which is very
very cool
there are paid tools that you can use
there are
free tools you can use but if you're
competing with somebody on the web you
can actually go get their data and you
can go understand how they are
successful or not and learn lessons from
what they are doing and go figure out
how to change your strategy in turn
it's also very important to understand
that
you can serve the needs of people who
want to buy from you right away or
donate money from you right away but
also people who are in the process of
just considering and that's the
difference between kind of people are
very close to becoming customers versus
people who are going to be prospects
it's going to take them a while to get
converted
and the last thing of course is all
about understanding that web analytics
does not simply affect what you do on
the web on mobile phones tablets or
desktop and laptops but actually what
happens to your offline existence if you
have a call center that will be
including web analytics if you have an
actual supermarket store or dealership
those things would be included so web
analytics at it at its holistic level is
the art and science of qualitative
quantitative analysis of your data and
your competition's data in order to
drive improvements to the consumer
experience online and to drive business
outcomes online and offline and that's
what makes it so very exciting in this
particular video i want to cover the the
incredible opportunity that exists in
using data online in solving key
business problems
as well as outlined for you some of the
more specific things that you can do
once you do start using web analytics
and sort of aspirationally all of the
other more wonderful things that are
over the horizon that you'll be able to
take advantage of once you start
creating a truly data-driven business
now why would you want to do web
analytics a lot of people ask me this
question and honestly it surprises me
because
if you're not
wanting deeply profoundly desiring to be
data-driven
then
really there is no honest way to survive
in the world that we live in today as
all different channels come together and
online continues to dominate growth for
companies and growth for non-profits as
a matter of fact but let me crystallize
why you should invest in web analytics
in a very simple way when you take out
an ad in a magazine and try and measure
its success in this case an ad for chevy
malibu all of the measures for success
are interpretive or proxy driven for
example you take out an ad in the time
magazine and the best proxy you have for
measuring success is the number of
subscribers the magazine has you have
absolutely no idea how many people might
have opened the magazine how many people
might have bothered to even see a
gorgeous little ad
and and much less you would know how
many people then went to a dealership
and might have purchased the product
that you're selling in this magazine ad
but if you think about it when you take
out that exact same ad in this case on
google
or yahoo or microsoft or aol or or any
other property in the world the ad that
shows up right here at the very top it
does not require you to use your faith
to measure success you can use data to
measure success because you can measure
exactly how many people saw the ad you
can measure how many people clicked on
the ad how many people interacted with
the ad and finally if people do come to
your website as a result of this ad
you're able to measure how many people
customize a car set up a appointment at
the dealership downloaded a brochure and
and all of the outcomes that are
available for that single ad that you
took so the measurement of success
rather than being interpretive and proxy
driven is direct
it is specific and it is scalable and i
cannot think of a better more powerful
and profound reason for you to use web
analytics than that it moves you away
from making business decision based on
faith and what you believe in to
shifting to using data and bringing a
massive amount of accountability to the
processes that you're executing for your
business
it behooves us to cover the definition
of web analytics so when we when we say
web analytics what do you mean and in
writing my second book i had created
this definition and the definition quite
simply says web analytics is the
analysis of qualitative and quantitative
data for your website and the
competition to drive continual
improvement of the online experience of
your customers and prospects which
translates into desired outcomes online
and offline and let me just highlight a
couple of different things in this
definition now the very first thing
that is important for all of us to
realize is that we're talking about
qualitative as well as quantitative data
most of the time when people think about
web analytics they think about all the
clicks that we collect on the website
and while that continues to be one of
the largest sources of data we analyze
web analytics is also surveys and lab
usability testing and follow me homes
and
the various other methodologies we can
use to understand why people behave the
way they do on our website it also
includes analyzing your competition one
of the most amazing things about the web
is how much data you have access to for
all of your competition
for any given website in the world you
can use tools like compete and transfer
websites and others to try and
understand how many people went to my
competitors website how long did they
stay and what did they do so that you
can learn from the analysis of data for
for your competitor and improve your
business also it's about improving
things every single day not opening
tools once in a while and and trying to
see if you can find something to change
but actually improving things every
single day in small bits and we're going
to cover this in this video
and finally it's about both online and
offline while the name web the word web
exists in the name web analytics web
analytics is very much about
understanding the offline impact of all
of the online activities that you do on
your store on the phone center on on
sort of other existence you have like a
call center you might have offline but
it also means that web analytics is
great at understanding the online impact
of your offline activities such as
television campaigns and radio and
magazine ads and etc etc so it's
important to realize that web analytics
is not simply about analyzing the clicks
on of people who come to your website
but it's a much more expansive view of
qualitative and quantitative competitive
data in order to improve your online
existence
some people also think that it's really
really hard to get going and i think
this is one of the biggest biggest
wrong beliefs that people have if i want
to start by tracking a website in this
case let's say my blog arkham's razor
all i have to do is go to a web
analytics tool i could start with a free
tool called google analytics or a free
tool called yahoo's web analytics both
really wonderful tools i would simply
open an account i would copy this code
from this website from the google
analytics or yahoo analytics website
literally i copy this few lines of code
i go back to my website i open the
footer file of my website as you can see
clearly it's in this case i'm using a
php driven websites photo.php i paste
the code into this file that i have on
my website there you go now you can see
those exact lines of code pasted into
this into this file
and boom i sing happy birthday
right
75
of the data that you will need in order
to make decisions using clickstream
tools can be gotten just by doing these
three simple steps on your website and
any gorgeous data flows in and you might
perhaps be thinking well what can i get
for a few lines of code right just a few
reports
no that's the surprise here are all of
the reports that you can get from this
particular tool
uh google analytics in this case and and
i'm gonna hide with with little bit
transparently white all the data you
won't get if you do what i just said and
notice the massive amounts of data you
can get about visits and locations and
languages and mobile traffic and page
views and sources and keywords and
search engines girls and everything you
can get
so i hope that i've answered the
question
web
analytics and why right web first
analytics second why third you want to
do web analytics because it increases
accountability for the efforts you're
going to put on the web you want to do
web analytics because it lowers risk and
enables you to fail faster than anybody
else so that you win
at a greater magnitude than was ever
possible
and you should do web analytics because
it is one of the most powerful business
drivers that will lead to a long-term
success for your business i have yet to
meet a single business that is going to
win on the web without having a
well-defined web analytics process and
strategy and with that we have come to
the end of this video on web analytics
full course i hope it was informative
and interesting if you have any
questions about the topics covered in
this video please ask away in the
comment section below our team will help
you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here